Gentlemen,
very sorry for the late start here,
but uh,
unfortunately I'm the only one that's
here.
Uh,
Brian and Eddie and Ari have not shown
up yet.
Brian's not showing up because he,
uh,
he was eating some yogurt and he bit
down on his spoon and broke his fucking,
which is,
uh,
one of the dumbest things I've ever
heard in my life.
So he's not going to be here and I'm not
stuck in traffic because it's raining in
La and when it rains in la,
everybody freaks out and are stuck in
traffic as well.
So that's the story.
Let me shut this off.
I've got this.
The Guru from gang starr died yesterday.
Very,
very sad.
One of my favorite rap bands ever.
Um,
and tutors,
only 43 years old.
It makes you stay.
That's only a year older than me.
That's crazy.
Shit.
You know,
dying of cancer and shit used to be
healthy.
Now he's dead and that's life
unfortunately.
But the good thing is we still got this
music life carries on and uh,
maybe,
maybe somewhere cooler right now,
right?
Who the fuck knows,
right ladies.
Gentlemen?
So,
uh,
since I'm starting Solo,
let's get started with a bunch of shit
that's going on.
First of all,
this fucking strikeforce thing.
You know,
one of the reasons why the strikeforce
thing is so fucked up is because they
haven't really done it that many times.
They haven't done these big CBS shows
that many times and they made a bunch of
big mistakes and the big brawl that
happened afterwards.
I mean,
first of all,
everyone was criticizing mayhem and
everyone was saying that may have fucked
up and made him like cost CBS.
They're deal.
Alright first of all may have,
shouldn't have even been allowed to get
into that octagon if that was the UFC.
They have security at the stairs.
They have security at the top.
There's,
you can't just walk into the octagon.
Well the fights are going on.
It's literally not possible.
You can't have that many teammates in
the,
in the octagon as well when,
you know,
when Jake shields,
after his fight,
he had like seven,
six or seven of his buddies in the cage.
Trainers,
everybody.
You can't have that many people.
The UFC does not allow the UFC,
I believe you're allowed to have three
and they regulate it all and that's what
you supposed to do as far as mayhem
doing something that was inappropriate.
Well,
he definitely did something
disrespectful.
You know,
Jake shields is in the middle of the
biggest victory of his life.
Just beads.
Damn fucking Henderson and dominates
them for four rounds after we got fucked
up for the first round.
So you know,
it's a huge emotional victory for him
and for his teammates.
His teammates rather,
you know,
this is a gigantic fight and he pulled
it off.
So,
you know,
emotions were running very high and
mayhem stepped in and,
and Bogart at the attention.
And that's not.
But it was a mistake,
you know,
he went in there to try to hype up the
fight the same way they would do in the
UFC the same way.
You know,
the famous George St Pierre.
I'm not impressed with your performance.
You know,
when he went in there when Matt Hughes
had just one,
you know,
that kind of shit happens to build up
fights.
That's what it's for.
But this wasn't planned,
you know,
strikeforce didn't know what was going
to happen,
may have thought about it last minute.
He just wanted a,
you know,
who was hyped up because he had one
earlier than [inaudible] 91 or to
rematch with jake shields.
So he runs into the octagon and uh,
you know,
they start pushing them out of the way
and then chaos erupts.
He should've never been allowed to get
into the octagon.
And if he was allowed to get into the
cage,
they should have had it regulated.
It should have been a situation where
when,
you know,
they would let jake shields speak.
They ask them all the questions are
gonna.
Ask him totally respectfully.
He gets his chance.
He gets his moment to say what he has to
say,
thank his teammates.
Then after all that's done,
then mayhem comes in.
If that's what they want.
If that's a fight,
they're hyping up next.
Who the fuck knows what their plans
were?
They,
their,
their plans might not be a mayhem fight
next.
So it should have been up to them a,
they should have,
they should have regulated the cage.
They should have made sure he didn't get
in there as far as like what the Diaz
brothers did and you know,
and Gilbert Melendez,
those guys have backing up there buddy.
All right.
Those guys are like brothers.
You know those guys.
They're all a bunch of fucking psychos
and savages.
They're their buddy just wins the
strikeforce middleweight title.
Some pushing goes on there down to get
in there.
That's just the way they are,
you know.
I mean the Diaz brothers,
you know,
people always criticize them,
but I think first of all I've been
getting they shit way more interesting
when you've got someone like nate and
Nick Diaz that they don't give a fuck.
Like they really don't give a fuck.
Like they're not just pretending to not
give a fuck.
They'll do really don't give a fuck.
They will fight in a brawl on CBS on
prime time.
They don't give a fuck.
They really knew what was going on and
they still stepped in there.
Did that.
You can't just have them all together
like that and let anybody in that you
want.
It's like I used to have pit bulls and
when you get a bunch of pit bulls in the
room,
you can't get mad at the pit bulls if
they fight each other.
That's just what they do and these kinds
of professional mixed martial arts
fighters and in mixed martial arts,
definitely there's a psychological
aspect to it that's a huge component of
of fighting and whether or not you win
or lose and these guys have this
psychological edge over their opponents
because they're so aggressive because
they're so down to fight at any moment's
notice.
They don't give a fuck.
They're not afraid.
They're ready to throw down,
and because of that,
that's a significant advantage.
It's a significant tactic when it comes
to fighting and they're not going to
relinquish that just because they're on
national television.
So if someone gets some other boys'
faces and disrespects them,
they're kind of fight.
I mean,
that's just what's going to happen.
So what I blame is I think mayhem
certainly made an error,
but you should've never been allowed to
get into the position to make that
error.
It was completely,
in my opinion,
on strikeforce or the committee or
whoever the fuck is supposed to be
watching that cage,
you know,
I don't know who's responsible for that.
The UFC takes care of all that shit.
I never have to think about it.
But whoever was responsible for that,
it was a god disaster.
So that's,
uh,
that's my,
my opinion on that.
And as far as like the commentary goes
and if people were talking about how bad
the commentary is,
this is what I'm think about that I like
frank shamrock.
I liked Francek frank shamrock as a
person.
I enjoy them.
I think he's funny.
Um,
I don't mind this commentary at all
those other two dudes.
So like my mom said,
if you don't have anything nice to say,
don't say anything at all.
So I'm not gonna say Shit because I
think those guys need work,
you know,
it's not as easy as it looks and you got
to be a fan of the sport.
And um,
I'm not sure that the main guys a fan of
the sport,
I don't even want to mention his fucking
name.
So,
um,
here we are,
this is the,
the,
the four slash 20 episodes of the
podcast and what we'll do is I'll just
ramble until everybody gets here already
in it.
He should be here within probably 15 to
20 minutes depending on what the traffic
looks like and when they get here,
then we'll jump off.
So between now and then I'll just take
questions.
If you see my office here,
if you notice it's things have changed.
I got rid of some shit here,
move something out and I'm going to put
a green screen behind me.
So,
uh,
for the next ustream stream podcasts,
hopefully the next one if not the next
one,
the one after that I'll be in space.
So the way we're going to have it set up
is we're going to have a podcast,
then I'm going to,
how I'm going to have a green screen,
I'm going to have a,
a total space background and then I'll
have couches and shit like that.
So the idea is that it'll look like
couches flying through space.
And so that should be pretty
interesting.
This whole thing is,
you know,
I started out this podcast sort of just
kind of as a roof and uh,
you know,
I just thought it'd be an interesting
thing to do.
I'd always wanted to do something like
that.
I always enjoyed radio,
but uh,
I kind of never got off my ass to do it.
And now I've done it.
I think this is like the twelfth or the
13th week in a row.
So,
uh,
we've been real consistent and uh,
it's been a lot of fun.
And now it's number eight on the comedy
section of Itunes,
which is crazy because the audio part of
it was just sort of an afterthought to
throw that up.
And ustream one is getting plenty of
it's and it's,
um,
it's good fun.
It's a fun way to supplement,
you know,
comedy.
And I'm speaking academy.
I got one Gig,
uh,
this Friday night and Sacramento,
but it's already sold out.
I'm going to be doing the color
commentary for a joe say Aldo versus
Uriah Faber.
Um,
the,
uh,
I don't think they're,
they're literally not even referring to
it as the WEC.
They're just referring to it as although
versus favor,
I'm not exactly sure why that is.
I think,
you know for now because it's because
the preliminary is going to be on spike
TV lot,
a lot,
a lot of corporate shit.
So that's what's going on.
I got a bunch of stuff to talk about.
First of all,
this fucking volcano over Iceland is
nuts.
If you haven't noticed that there's a.
my wife had no idea what was going on
because she doesn't pay attention to
shit except for gossip.
But uh,
the uh,
there's a,
a giant volcano in Iceland.
It literally is erupting through the
ice.
It's pretty bad ass.
We look at some of the video footage
online.
If you google it,
it's really pretty intense.
You seeing like molten lava squirting up
through the ice is really wild and the
volcanic ash has gotten so bad that they
have canceled all the air flight,
uh,
over Europe for days and days.
Oh,
our spheres here.
How'd you get in?
Oh,
beautiful.
Right for this place out.
I did.
See,
ladies and gentlemen,
he's here.
Eddie Bravo shouldn't be moments behind.
I'm sure he's very close.
Could even ring the doorbell.
No,
he didn't.
I didn't even hear it.
Not so much a rambling.
We're talking about the,
um,
the Iceland volcano and you know that.
I'm not sure.
Nobody can fly anywhere today.
They just lifted it,
but I wouldn't fucking fly it fully.
Yeah.
They lifted the air,
the air band over Europe,
but that's because it's costing them
$200,
million dollars a day.
You know?
How many is that?
The airline industry in this country.
I know.
It's all crazy.
$200.
Million dollars a day.
How about that?
How fragile is this world and any little
thing can happen and things closed down
for a couple of days.
And these businesses there,
they run so on the edge that just a
couple days off work and they to come
close to being bankrupt.
I like people like fucking hurls doors
with his full carrier can't fly home.
And I'm like,
you know what?
We could've had all life.
White people have no idea what volcanoes
are all about.
Volcanoes have reshaped this earth.
Like when you're in Hawaii,
you get,
if you ever got the line yet,
we've gone over the volcano and a
helicopter.
It's the fucking coolest thing ever.
Uh,
I went to the big island and we took a
trip on a helicopter and we flew over
the volcano and you're flying over this
active volcano.
You're watching the lava bubble up
inside.
You can see the fucking line,
you can see it and you could see it roll
into the ocean.
Like we fly over to where it rolls in
the ocean.
It's moving four inches every year
closer to Japan,
fucking crazy.
And there's another island,
there's another island in the middle of
the ocean that hasn't quite popped up
yet,
but it's on its way.
It's going to be the next island and the
Hawaiian islands underneath on its way.
It's building up.
That whole area is just one gigantic
stuff comes out.
It just draws your eyes and it becomes
a,
it becomes rock and then it breaks down
and becomes dirt and plants grow on it.
Yeah,
I mean it literally is that,
that's what Hawaii is.
It's a volcano and it just came out of
the ground and,
and created islands,
but you could see the fucking volcano
and they have all these different photos
that you could buy there and videos you
could watch out.
There's a bunch of towns that were
completely wiped out on the big island
where they'll show you where the town
used to be.
The lava just came rolling in like the
fifties and just crush the entire town.
I think it happened in the 18 bullets.
I'm going to catch up.
I didn't see any of that,
but I'm sure there must be.
I mean,
most of the stuff just gets smushed.
The lot of that comes down.
It's just literally annihilates any
evidence whatsoever that anything was
there as well.
People don't realize is that she just
happened so many times.
You know,
this world has changed so many times,
just in the last few million years.
The,
um,
the best place to find mega donald
skeletons.
Meglawn teeth.
You know what a mega is there?
The,
these giant,
ancient prehistoric sharks.
They're like fucking way bigger than
great wines.
Well,
the best place to find their teeth is in
Montana recovers.
It used to be the ocean.
How fucking fucking crazy Montana used
to be under water,
you know,
so many parts of let's just,
uh,
just like 10,000
years ago,
half of North America was under a mile
high sheet of ice just 10,000
years ago.
That's nothing.
Ten thousand years is nothing.
Ten thousand years ago they were saber
tooth tigers and woolly mammoths because
you know,
that just 10,000
years ago,
fucking Saber Tooth Tigers,
10,000
years isn't shit.
There are people around them.
What was the $10,000
for that?
We don't know.
Ten thousand years before that.
I mean,
it was sort of human civilization.
It's all who the fuck knows.
I mean,
we know that the big extinction was 65
million years ago.
That was the,
you know,
the one that hit the Yucatan,
the big meteor or girl that wiped out
supposedly wiped out everything.
So small mammals and anything bigger
than like a fucking hamster was go.
Why were they figured out a way to
burrow underground and hardy rats and
shit like that,
you know,
rats or some party animals,
and we're like the descendants of
anything that survived 65 million years
while the rest will,
all sorts of mammals.
I mean,
and some birds,
I mean just dinosaurs are direct to set
or birds or direct descendant of
dinosaurs.
Somehow or another,
some birds survive,
but literally most of the life on the
planet was wiped the fuck out.
And then there's the super volcanoes,
men super volcanoes and been wiping out
things on this continent for millions
and millions of years.
Every six to 800,000
years of yellowstone blows up and
literally wipes out the whole continent,
kills everything whenever we started
speaking.
And there's been 2000 earthquakes in
yellowstone national park since January
of this year
of earthquakes.
And how there's so many more now.
Is that true?
No,
no,
exactly the same.
Just happened to big cities.
Really?
Yeah.
So there's the same amount.
It's just a hitting places where people.
Yeah,
and if it happens,
I mean if you had an earthquake in
Bakersfield,
as long as the damage,
if we get it on the corner of sunset and
Fairfax,
it's going to be tremendous,
you know,
but it seems like there's so many of
them.
They seemed like a lot.
Is that because of,
uh,
the news,
like there's more access to information
now.
Last year was the year of celebrity
death,
you know,
it wasn't,
know it never had before,
but it just keeps happening.
I shouldn't have done it last year with
Jackson.
That chick that was hot.
It was a choice.
Angeles,
that's your legacy chick.
That was hard.
It was in Charlie's angels.
Oh yeah.
Did he died last year or this year?
Because we did that episode about beer.
Slippery.
They're already talking about it openly
and we talked about it.
A bunch of celebrities are dying,
but it's not,
it's just,
I think it's just tmz makes more people.
Celebrities.
That's true.
You know,
there's,
there's way more celebrities down in
there before.
Do you know gangster rap band.
Gangsta Guru from gang starr just die.
You don't give a fuck.
Did I just barely existed?
Already knew is that you never heard him
sing their songs.
You don't sing or rap.
One of the stories.
I'll play you one second.
Video Guru,
but a great person.
There might be one of the best like
lyrical bands,
the 99 populous and he died last night,
apparently had cancer and now you just
got this accompany cancer.
40th three bucks.
That's like me.
I'm almost 43 artists trying to natural
causes not get hit by a fucking shit.
Just gave us a song.
So he was,
he was not seen in true romance where
these,
like a year ago Williams not.
Yeah.
So it was Christopher walken and in the
air,
the guy,
uh,
so you people know who the guy from.
What was he going to remember that
movie?
That was awesome.
Waterworld believed that Jesus Christ,
he's under 100 pounds.
Wow.
Can be hot.
But the weirdest fucking thing in the
world is these women that think they're
being super skinny,
like anorexic is hot.
That shit is disgusting.
It's more some people like how could
have fucking any guide like that.
That's so anti nature nature.
You want a woman that has a fatter ass.
You want her to take tests,
she can milk the baby.
You want to have her answer.
She can survive the pregnancy.
Those are all like dessert,
but those things are good,
but that's why those things are there.
That traffic tickets,
the reason why they're attractive,
it's like actions
because that's too much.
That's obese.
That's unhealthy,
but a little bit of fat is good.
Like a little fat fast.
Just like Tony.
That's not good because they can't move
around.
Good.
You want athletic,
but you want some fat on them.
That's what it is.
It's all nature.
It's all leftover shit.
I mean,
think about how easy it is to trick your
system.
How about fake tits?
We know they're fake.
We know there's a bag of plastic
underneath your skin,
but still it makes you.
It looks hotter.
They poke out and they look ridiculous
like that poor fucking girl.
What is her name?
Heidi Montag.
Do you know what machines is?
Yeah,
he don't.
He doesn't pay attention.
He's the anti gossip man,
but there's a heidi mom tag chick is a.
she's one of those celebrities for just
being a celebrity,
like you're not exactly sure why she.
She just had 10 plastic surgeries
altogether.
She had her chin on her tits done.
She had all these shirts that are worth.
Some people say she looks better,
but I didn't think she looked bad to
begin with.
She just had to kind of a big chin,
like sorta like a Jay Leno thing going
on.
But she was pretty like,
you know,
like she didn't have to do that.
Like it doesn't make you look better.
It just makes you like different.
Definitely sluttier.
She had big tents to begin with.
She had a big fake tits and she got
giant one,
so now they're like ridiculous.
Like they look stupid.
I like a solid suit.
Sounds good.
It's amazing.
But it's like crazy.
Crazy book.
Yeah.
When you see girls who have.
It's so funny,
like La is so fucked up with fake test
that you see girls got real tense of the
kind of like sagging.
Show those what's wrong.
While
it's just like,
that's normal,
let's go look at fucking videos of
Africa.
You know,
you're not supposed to have these,
these missile tests that stick straight
out of your chest.
That shit's not normal.
I think they look real nice,
but I grew up in like a feed with the
two.
It's still hanging out a little bit.
Just pull it just looked like they did
when they were pointing.
It's amazing though,
how,
how easy it is to trick us sunglasses.
It was good to me.
More of those people,
you know,
it's like you've got the right surgery,
right?
You look great.
To me more is 47 years old and she still
looks God.
How the fuck is she doing that?
I saw that.
That's incredible.
The model with the book there shirt,
but it's not that much in person.
She was at a UFC maybe two years ago,
so she's be 47,
48.
She's hot as fuck dude.
Still,
you know,
I'm sure the vaginas just done.
I'm sure this is drives.
Fuck yeah.
There's no more blood coming out of that
time.
There's no more periods.
15 when you had 15,
that's a wrap.
No more periods.
That means you're not oscillating means
you're not really able to have babies
anymore.
Your body starts to fuck off.
You're just shooting loads into a
cemetery and shooting those into a
casket.
Got that in there.
It's still it's intelligent trick.
You might as well be fucking a rubber
doll.
I mean you're having sex with a person
that's all well and good,
but as far as like you shooting a load
inside of her,
it's a total waste of time,
but we don't want to.
I'm not saying that,
but I'm saying like for nature it's like
a Jew.
I mean the only reason why sex feels
good is to trick you into fucking so
that you make
would say with a Jewish mystical theory
about what he wants to know when you
pull out or when you masturbate,
your semen is said to have been pregnant
at some demon will make.
It's like they're like appearance right
here and she just fucking you as your
last rating redness.
Then when you get to heaven or 40 of
them in this purgatory level,
you have to face all your kids and
they're like,
why?
Why couldn't we be born real people and
they're all like formed and mangled and
you have to answer all of them.
Oh my God.
That might be the greatest story.
How come on?
How Much Kabbalah?
Because they taught me this when you
were a child and other people that don't
know are you spent a bunch of years and
is used as a seriously religious man?
Like read the Torah.
How many hours a day?
When I was in Israel,
I don't know,
10,
12,
12 hours a day.
Reading the Torah.
We're going to have to fire up the
volcano for that.
Son got paid to go ahead and this is
great,
man.
You really revamped.
Oh Dude.
I'm turning this into a real studio.
Did a solo.
It took like 12 hours.
I did have people help me get rid of the
desk.
Ladies and gentlemen,
if you ever heard of a volcano,
you know what a volcano is.
A volcano is a vaporizing device and
what a vaporizer and you know,
the big argument about thc about
marijuana in general is that you
shouldn't smoke and the smoke is bad for
your lungs.
Well,
you don't have to smoke it,
you can eat it,
but eating is very tricky because he
didn't get too fucked up because when
you eat it,
it's processed by the liver and it
creates something called 11 hydroxy
metabolite,
which is four times more psychoactive
than thc.
And it's really a totally different
experience,
you know,
that's why people get freaked out.
That's why,
you know,
I'm sure a lot of you have seen that
video where that dude,
he's a cop and he calls up,
um,
the uh,
nine slash 11 and says that he thinks
he's dying because,
because he and his girlfriend aid some
pot brownies and uh,
he says,
time was moving really slow and he
thinks he's dying.
Well,
let's see,
gentlemen.
Oh,
to get the office cleaned.
This mother Fucker,
dude,
I got rid of the desk and I'm turning
this thing into a school.
You,
we live right now.
There's over 2000 people.
This is the biggest crowd we've ever had
anywhere else.
That's a vaporizers and vaporizers
please gentlemen,
it blows into this plastic bag and it
looks like,
like a,
like a
no
Saran wrap or some shit and you just get
pure thc vapor.
And what it does is it heats up the
little crystals on the thd and releases
them and it comes out like missed.
So there's no smoke at all.
So there's no argument anymore.
There's no negative health effects.
I'm going to have two dedicated cameras
in here and this is going to be a green
screen and we're going to be in space.
What I set this up within two weeks.
This will all be green behind us.
And then what we'll watch,
it wouldn't be like we're flying to the
universe on a couch because every
episode is a different person than they
were in Africa.
So,
uh,
what we're talking about,
we went over volcanoes.
We went over,
I went over strikeforce.
I don't know if you've got any opinion
on strikeforce.
I said the whole reason why that brought
took place is because they didn't,
they didn't guard the cage,
they didn't do a good job of making sure
that nobody got in there.
That was the finance was like,
I want to go this bottom,
like this spice done.
It's over and over one.
Well,
and what may have went in there and
talked with jake shields was in the cage
and said,
Yo,
Jay,
but am I getting the rematch?
Gilbert Melendez push made him out of
the way.
The Diaz brothers jumped,
may,
have,
may have pushed up,
jumped in.
It was a brawl to lose kicking him.
When he was down,
it was like four people on.
Um,
Eric Apple took jake shields and got
them out of there and push them over to
the other sides and being involved in
the Bra.
I mean,
it was a fucking a bench clearing brawl.
So it was pretty awesome.
That was a great.
There's a great picture online where
someone from the audience captured it on
their phone or something where jake
shields and nick are coming.
It's like from behind change or behind
me.
Yeah,
it's a great.
man was standing there and Nick Diaz is
like this and jake shields is like that.
Gilbert Melendez on the other side,
those fucking dudes,
they have a lot of unity and I respect
that and you know,
and everybody's like,
oh,
there is
isn't there,
this and that.
Well,
you got to realize,
man,
these dudes are fucking professional
cage fighters.
Right?
During their scrapping with each other
every day they're down to die for each
other.
The reputation is hugely important.
They're not going to fucking back down.
They're not going to have a situation
where they look like a bitch.
They're not going to allow someone to
think of them.
Anybody who think that their buddy got
disrespected but they didn't do anything
about it.
That's not gonna happen.
So any,
any sort of a situation like that where
we're all takes place.
I played fucking strikeforce.
I blame strikeforce for allowing that to
get to that deposition.
Allowing those fucking do to get into
the cage.
Was abroad the comments or last week?
Yeah,
there were some.
That's people that everyone's scared of.
They him to leave and it lit up as far
as the front patio and allegory.
I was scared.
They were like,
just call the cops and get them out of
here,
but they wouldn't do it.
Eventually fight broke out and some of
the let's go put front and I saw the
fight and I'm like,
I don't want to get involved with this.
I don't get stabbed for someone else
already.
Let's go fight.
Well,
it's like everybody,
like everybody in as the enforcer now,
seriously come on for the reasons that
some guys were like,
oh,
so how long have you been doing?
Did you choke me out?
You might be the baddest motherfucker.
Did you hear what Gus Johnson sale under
Johnson said,
somebody I.
This hasn't been confirmed,
but I'm just going to say it because I
hope it's true.
Gus Johnson,
who's the guy who's the black dude,
he does the commentary.
Strikeforce made a bunch of errors
called like arm bars.
I was like,
this.
See this,
ladies and gentlemen,
see the fogging that that's missed.
Well,
anyway,
this reporter called them up and ask him
about it.
I think it was Mike Russell,
his name,
and he said,
listen dog,
I know the Gypsy bar.
Kamala Khan more.
I trained.
He said,
if you want to come down and roll with
me,
I'll show you the difference.
Like he's challenging guys to roll with
it.
Like he trades like Gus Johnson on the
Internet.
Yes.
Mike Russell on the Internet yet?
No,
it's too far.
We can pull the scores but it.
But we put close to.
The problem is there's three of us here
can read it.
They can't read it.
We don't have to read it.
You could just talk.
We got to pay attention to the audience.
Yeah,
but you can't pay attention to the
audience and keep a conversation going
at the same time.
Yeah.
That's not really questioning.
Lumped it all.
Yeah.
Have be great if like if the dea busted.
We're all legal.
We have prescription.
Yeah.
Were legal and I wouldn't mind some are
crackers back up and I'll fill the bag
up again more seriously though.
Seriously,
because there's the 4:20
episodes we should be allowed to have
like order pizza during the show.
It's for 20.
We're getting high,
like snacking on shit that fucks up with
the flux of the conversation.
Never had a great conversation and
eating pizza.
But yeah,
but people are watching this
conversation.
This conversation is like a show,
but I'm talking about how it all
started.
I said,
why don't you just go walk into my
kitchen and just go scrounge around the
way we've got a show to do something
where people order pizza pizza later and
the idea will be the pizza comes right
before we killed this now.
Okay,
how dare you motherfuckers.
So I'm artist telling us something
hilarious.
Listen to this shit.
Stop.
Need to,
need to be focusing on show sun.
Ra was telling us that there's a,
an ancient Jewish,
whatever the fuck it is,
Jewish mystical thought.
There's a waste.
The waste statement.
So,
um,
they say when you pull out and not
really math,
reading your fucking woman was nothing.
Just like a ghost.
And when you go,
when you go through a place,
all your kids would have been born in
the real life.
Even a woman.
And like,
like why did you pull out?
We want him to be born real boys.
Didn't have any kids.
You've got a building.
You've got a billion monster babies.
I think it's per load.
You're like fucking one Venus?
I think so.
So how many games do you think you got?
Dammit,
I'm going to have a much more efficient
set up here as well with this gentleman
when we get back on an average day for
weeks.
My belief,
since you shouldn't six loads a week,
sometimes more than one of those.
Do you ever feel like a loser when you
get to live?
If I jerk off more than once a day that
I'm just obsessed.
Bad.
That's bad.
Obviously.
I'm not morning already.
Jerked off.
I know,
but why?
Why?
Just sit there like a monkey?
Yeah.
While you're fucking.
You know,
you'd be bad at reading,
spreading the seed that's ready to seed.
You're jerking off into a Napkin.
Vagina.
Then if there was a good job to do,
no one has ever said no.
I'd rather just check off.
I'm sorry.
Telling you that masturbation is so bad
that you're fucking.
That's like the worst case scenario.
You're having sex with the demon and
make it half demon babies that are going
to be waiting for you when you die to
scream and yell at you.
That is because the institution of
marriage,
they want that.
That helps religion people making units
and it's amazing though.
Like what?
Why do they give a fuck?
I don't know.
Why don't you give a fuck if you
masturbate?
What is,
what is it about masturbation?
About no masturbation,
you know that somehow or another equates
to them having more control over you
with the more you don't have to pay,
the more you want.
Fuck,
fuck.
Women face.
So the results of Vegas,
the morning mass with Less Vegas.
So that's got to be example why the
Catholic Church doesn't want you to any
birth control too,
right?
Yes.
That makes sense.
Yeah.
Well it's definitely way for someone
when they have kids.
I feel that myself.
I feel like I'm easier to control now
that you have kids,
when you,
when you have kids and you want
everything to be nice,
you know you want everything to be easy.
I don't want any drama,
you know,
turn them like this,
but man it a demon babies,
you're,
you're fucking demon thing.
They came up with the worst story ever.
You fucking a demon and you make babies
that are half demon and they're waiting
for you when you die.
What the fuck man,
Mr stuff.
It's like,
why stop?
Because you know,
by the time we figured that out,
you've already checked off like a
thousand times 50,000
demons.
I'm fucked either way.
Might as well enjoy this.
Be something you could do to cancel out
the other demons to make up for it.
There's got to be like,
what if you let it lie at 12 babies you
know with,
with your wife,
but masquerade three times you get to
heaven.
You have three little dema babies.
You're still gonna like tasks
do on earth that cancel out your demon
babies because they're.
There's got to,
there's got to me.
Because what about people that are
trying to convert to this religion?
I would,
I that the Jews don't give a fuck.
I already got $75,000
recruiting religion ever.
They don't give a fuck.
We tried to convince me not to do it.
Yeah.
They make it really hard.
Also is a Jewish thing.
It's like a regular Jewish.
You were saying all of them.
You don't want to lie.
I never heard of this before.
I never heard of it either you,
your old tests,
but they're like chapter.
It is the Torah.
Fairly decent study that took like 10
hours a,
you know,
you remember when David was the king of
the Jews are so powerful that they
wouldn't allow any conversions.
Wow.
There were like no one's doing cameras
get that's deep.
And you guys,
uh,
um,
what do you guys think of Jesus that he
was a real person,
spoke about things.
He was,
it was a,
like a sort of a wise man,
but they went off the deep end.
So they look down on Christianity for
choosing Jesus as their savior and Lord.
Uh,
yes,
they're excited that none of those other
shoes.
It's so funny how they're all sort of,
kind of connected like Judaism just
Sorta,
Kinda connected with Christianity
included.
That's why the,
um,
all the really conservative
fundamentalist Christians wanted to
control Israel and support Israel to
believe in the rapture and they believed
that when the shit goes down best place
to be like you have to protect them,
but they believe that they're wrong.
Even though the Bible says that they're
the chosen people,
the Christians to go,
yeah,
but you guys kept the story.
I'll fucked up.
We got it right and don't be an awesome
thing for the Jews.
If it came out,
the Jesus actually never existed.
Wouldn't be like,
dude,
you guys,
he never even existed.
That would have been crushed.
The Christian truth.
Do they have that Jesus documents,
man,
and apparently that's very much a debate
very much in debate.
Yeah.
There's a lot of scholars to do not
believe he was an actual person because
they believe that Jesus existed but just
wasn't mad.
Jews believe that Jesus existed and he
was mad and it would make it would
benefit their costs because they'll kill
each other if slicing each other.
If you weren't their religion.
I believe that they were the former Rep.
the great rabbis would talk about what
we will do it that makes me think that
he,
even though there isn't that much proof
that he actually wants to live in,
there's a lot of holes and that went bed
and the guy that never was all that
shit.
You.
How come?
How come the Jews and the Muslims don't
jump on that?
Jesus Christ never existed.
Well,
I exactly.
So that makes me think damn.
He probably was a man who was a bad
motherfucker.
Who knows?
But the issue is you can't send false
prophets.
They said there's many way.
The guy existed for sure.
He didn't walk on water and come back
from the dead.
That was like a.
like someone thinking Bruce Lee could
really beat up 50 people like Bruce Lee,
the real guy,
and Bruce Lee the superstar to different
people.
But it's how many people think their
life on some story that would not make
any fucking sense.
You told it today,
like if you told that story today and
said there was a dude who walked on
water and came back from dead.
Everybody wouldn't go.
Just shut the fuck up.
That's ridiculous,
but because it's 2000 years ago,
everybody's like,
oh,
that's,
you could be happy.
It's not like anything like rational
people that you talk to that would.
There was a
guy that we,
when we're doing fear factor,
who,
uh,
we did a family fear factor.
We came to people's houses and made him
do things and we traveled all across the
country.
This dude was a teacher.
He was a fucking math teacher and he was
telling me like scientifically that,
that Jesus existed because you can prove
it because they,
they,
they've looked at molecules that are too
complex to just occurred naturally.
This is a super,
that's a ridiculous argument and this is
super,
super smart guy.
And I was listening to them talk,
you know,
supposedly super smart guy and I was
listening to this guy talking like how
it is that,
but this guy can't see that.
He believes in some reason you can say
any courses assistant because something
is too amazing to exist.
National debt does not.
It's not true system.
I draw a picture of Jesus and with the
capture,
this is Jesus.
That's better,
right,
but you can never say that.
Nothing can exist naturally.
You don't know the power of nature.
Nature is absolutely ridiculous.
Completely unpredictable.
There's subatomic particles that blink
in and out of existence all the time.
They appeared in two places at once.
This is science,
real shit.
We know that exists in nature.
There's the whole pattern of nature is
gigantic.
The FIBONACCI sequence that you see in
Pine cones and pineapples and all sorts
of different plants and existence,
human facial features,
and this is like a mathematical code to
all this stuff.
It doesn't mean that there's a fucking
dude pressing the button.
It might mean that the whole thing is
just super complicated and conscious.
They did press in the but that there's a
god,
there's a duke.
We would want to break it down to like
someone like us.
We want to like make a super version of
us that's running for.
Yeah,
you're talking about that.
The old man with the beard and the sky.
Jesus every.
I'll know for sure.
Of course.
That's amazing.
I know of course,
but it sounded like you were saying that
you were describing how wonderful the
universities and the FIBONACCI theories
and how it's all like this code and
structure it to be a doctor like.
To me that was like that.
There is an intelligent other side that
is way too complex for us to understand
and this is what I don't think it is.
I mean it could be that everything has
an intelligence about what it is as a
single entity.
I think it's much more likely than an
interconnected thing.
We totally gray slacks like ocean when
the ocean and then we're like little
water molecules,
but it's the ocean.
It's all.
Exactly.
That's what psychedelic experiences we
like.
It feels like you're in the ocean
sometimes.
It feels like you're all connected all
around you to something that you don't
see those mushrooms.
I never told you.
I didn't find myself on a fucking
Thursday night.
I decided to a party by myself.
Did.
I took all those fucking mushrooms.
I got pictures and everything and from
the whole thing,
that wasn't five grands.
No,
no,
no.
It wasn't five.
I've got five grams before that was like
three and a half,
so I did them all myself and I'm just
want to let you know.
It was.
It was pretty fucking insane.
It was insane,
but not as intense is.
It would have been five brands.
It was pretty intense,
but the five grants was like dnt.
Five grams really is that threshold
point.
Boom.
That was about a year and a half ago
when I did the five grams and fucking I
was at a zoo and I just woke up in the
zoo.
I thought doing mushrooms at the zoo
would be fucking awesome.
You know what I mean?
Outdoors.
You did mushrooms,
go out in nature zoo,
but that is like anti nature.
Fuck.
I freaked the fuck out.
Get the fuck out.
You feel like you were in prison if you
were watching their sorrow for sure.
Like we just had to get the fog out.
Super negative.
Man.
I feel terrible when I go to the zoo.
I do not like it at all and it makes me
feel bad.
I used to enjoy it because I used to
enjoy caring for the animals,
but then one time I went one time when I
was super baked and when I did what I
did when I was super vague,
I got really.
I felt terrible.
I got really sad.
I thought it was a terrible,
terrible thing to do or doing was just
taking these animals and shoving them in
these cages and they don't even get to
do it and they just pace.
Had a polar bear at the La Zoo.
He'll just pace back and forth by that
back door,
just waiting for that fucking back white
door,
like fake ice and then a white dog,
white dog.
That's crazy.
That's horrible.
Man.
Mad and I freaked out.
Went out to the parking lot and this
chick I was with me,
we did the exact same thing and we saw
the exact same.
We looked at the mountains.
We would stop in the middle of a parking
lot because everything was connected.
It was all connected to look at this
guy.
This guy were dancing before and as tech
writing,
we look at the mountains in the
distance,
like miles away,
like passively in the mountains and all
of a sudden Aztec pattern.
The former,
the Aztec pattern.
There's,
what are you seeing?
What are you seeing as the Aztec
patterns?
Dense look at stuff.
The clouds,
the clouds are in their spot for a
second and then they formed.
And I remember connor telling me,
because congress is the one who turned
me onto the dude who had him.
He,
uh,
a sentencing.
He goes,
dude,
it's not the cloud's going to dance for
you.
Wow.
I didn't even pay attention to that
really badly.
We get in the fucking car.
Swear to God.
I was driving on the freeway freaking
out.
I didn't know if there was cars next to
me on the side of me,
but it really did look like as I was
driving on the freeway,
like,
like it wasn't like I was in the what
dreams may come.
Remember that Shit.
I was driving on the and it
was like rose petals and like bushes
would form in front of my car.
I'm driving really rose pedals and
bushes.
It was fucking insane by the way.
We don't want to encourage.
I just wanted to get.
I just trying to get home with terrible
mistake.
Exactly how I want her to do is get them
all getting my little fucking dark room
and just close my eyes and enjoy that
life show because that night's show was
fucking insane.
The twirling.
But you just kind of explain it.
It's just fucking.
And that's all I want.
I want to see.
Why do you think that you see certain
like religious symbolism and Hindu shit
and food an I got it from.
You think that's where they must be
doing mushrooms since the dawn of time.
Of course.
That's when I looked at him like that's
where all this shit comes from.
Alex Grey Shit telling you that's where
it's coming from.
These old like,
you know those things that I have in my
office,
the Gouda those birds,
you know those,
you know what I'm talking about.
And the media room.
I noticed there's crazy psychedelic furs
and when,
when I did the DMT ones much,
I saw those things.
I saw like that imagery and then when I
went to a store and saw them for sale,
I'm like,
oh my God,
whoever created that thing,
like was there.
Like they had to have seen that.
Like you could see that first.
You could say,
well why is that?
I don't know.
I mean,
is it something that's already there?
We just can't tune into it until we take
psychedelics?
Or is it the same hallucination happens
to every person that takes a drug.
I think.
I mean,
I don't know.
I think that it's just,
it opens up your sense that somehow to
this other dimension or all these
dimensions that are all around us and
like we're,
we're in a radio and we're only tuned
into 97 point one.
It has an infinite number of stations.
We're just going into another space
where that's possible is that I think it
just fucks with the branding.
Two things were possible.
I don't,
I don't personally think that.
I don't think that.
I don't think the shit that I'm seeing.
I don't know.
Interesting,
but the shit that with five grand,
five grand,
but the chicken,
what you is for me,
who knows?
It seems impossible for me to bring that
up in my brain like it's just the most
beautifully constructed flowing shapes
of random and you don't really.
You're not high.
You close your eyes and see like random
blackness and there's no pattern.
It's just like we might see who lit type
flashes of light,
but when you close your eyes,
I'm not sure.
All of a sudden there's this show that's
about a thousand times more complex than
that.
Visualize it.
You've got an item and that's pretty
fucking cool.
That visualized.
It's in that same vein but a thousand
times more complex way more complex and
I'm like,
I'm not designing this.
I'm not controlling this.
There's someone else controlling someone
else's making this shit,
not me.
It seems like that's definitely one
option,
but another option is that stuff
supercharges your perceptions and just
makes your imagination more
hypersensitive and it makes your brain
go wild because it reacts with,
you know,
the size that you use to see things as a
parasite.
It lives in the sewers and it only feeds
on cat springs.
So what it does is it took a worm,
right?
Yeah.
But it lets.
I'm a rat,
Ethan and the at Burlington the brain
and the only thing that changes the wrap
to the church and their behavior at all
except it takes their way,
their fear of cats.
So they will get eaten by a cab.
Everything else saying they gave and
when they see a capital like,
oh,
what's up?
Nothing major.
Cat kills it.
Uh,
yeah.
That's incredible.
And that's his brains.
I know.
Totally fine.
We talked about this one on the show.
The other one that they do where there's
a worm that gets inside of grasshopper,
convinced the grasshopper,
he commit suicide so that it can hatch
out of the spot it grows and how it gets
it teaches the grasshopper to jump into
the water and kill itself.
It's an aquatic warm,
so it has to be hatched in the fucking
water or things like that.
That's just crazy.
That's just like existing on a whole new
level of like,
just that alone right there is so
fucking amazing.
It's so amazing.
It's just another like,
you know,
there's something going on.
They started growing up I think.
Well there's definitely something going
on,
but I think our,
our idea that our culture is based on,
it's just that we wanted to be close to
us.
We want it to be like a super version of
us,
which is why would a,
God is like a super version of a human,
but you know,
with all these rules and God is,
you know,
fucking kind of addictive and gets
pissed at you if you fuck up and a lot
of religions is willing to kill you if
you don't listen to them.
You know,
we want it like a super version of box,
but it's much more possible that this,
this whole thing is just connected to
something that you can't stop.
You know,
some big,
powerful thing that feeds off itself.
All,
every,
everything.
This world has a role and plays a part
in this thing.
It's just we're used to it.
We don't realize how funny it really
fucking is because we're used to it
because it's just a normal part of our
day and people get used to anything.
People in Africa have giant plates.
They stick in their lips and all the
girls do it.
They're used to it.
We just get used to stupid shit and once
we're used to something then
everything's become spine.
And then we think that there's some sort
of a grand order.
Things,
you know,
it's,
it's really getting weirder and weirder.
As I got older,
as I got older and I look at,
you know,
our culture and I look at life on this
planet.
I look at my own mortality,
you know,
the fact that I'm like,
the next half of my life is going to be
half of my life were.
My buddies will work good.
You know,
that's just the way it is.
Getting close to dying.
You know you're going to have health
issues if you don't watch your diet,
you know you're going to make.
You have to make sure you get the proper
sleep or you might get heart attacks and
shit like things start going wrong.
Even when you,
when you really start assessing this
whole big picture of what this really is
like,
God,
it's like I feel I've been flying
without a manual for so long,
like just operating my life.
Not really having any idea how to do it
correctly just but learning from my fuck
ups starting from scratch.
We look.
I feel like there's such.
It's going to be a way better way to
learn life than the way we do it.
So is there a time you can get yourself
and your own personality figured out and
you're rolling the way he interacts with
people,
figuring out.
By the time you get that figured out so
god,
you're already dying
age.
They think,
Oh,
if I know what I do now,
and I go back to that age and you get
laid so much.
Oh God,
yeah.
Yeah.
Look like you were 34,
like 30 years.
Yeah.
Let we figured that shit on now.
More advancement.
Skincare for men.
It seems like you're not supposed to
live long enough to figure this out.
It seems like the reason why turtles
live to be a thousand years old and
people live to be 100 is because we're
not supposed to have a thousand years
toward us.
Discovery,
all the funding,
little geographic today,
thousand years old.
So they literally lived like back when
people were writing fucking what was the
thousand year old kid?
They should put like little black box
you to write everything out on paper.
I've written out a thousand years ago.
They might've been doing on animal skins
to a lot.
No,
that's crazy.
You know like the Dead Sea Scrolls.
That shit was all written on animal
skins.
Those motherfuckers didn't even know
paper.
They didn't even have paper back.
There could be a dead sea.
Scroll on a fucking turtle.
I wish I knew for sure who's
telling the truth about the Dead Sea
scrolls because I don't have enough time
to learn ancient Hebrew or what does an
era.
Man,
I can go back and read the Dead Sea
Scrolls and decipher for myself,
but there's all this dispute on what the
Dead Sea Scrolls actually means and some
people say that it contains all kinds of
nutty shit like fucking Ufo shows and
flying saucers and I mean there's,
there's guys who have decided from the
Dead Sea Scrolls,
like the John Marco Lego guy says it's
all about mushrooms.
You said it was about was them.
Even the them scary mushroom and
fertility rituals and he breaks it all
down like the origins of the words,
but people argue against him and I don't
know who's right.
It's too fucking live there on ABC.
They all the best scientists on the
planet and all the best linguists they
get together.
That should be important.
That's discipleship in front of the
world as a satellite feed from fucking
allegro passed away.
The Guy who wrote that book,
but he was the.
He was the one of the head guys for the
Dead Sea Scrolls.
You worked on it for 14 years and he was
the only agnostic in the group.
You know,
they had a bunch of people that were
ordained ministers and they were to
decipher is then we're all religious
people and he started out a religious
person,
but when you started studying theology
you realized somewhere along the line is
obviously bullshit and she just became
agnostic,
so he looked at the whole,
the whole picture completely different
than all the other guys.
So they all were refuted his findings.
But there's a lot of people that say
he's right and a lot of people will say
that.
He was the head scholar.
He was the number one dude.
If he was the guy who had it all,
like he was the guy who was looking at
it objectively and everybody else was
looking at it with a religious slant
because fucking guys thinks it was all
about mushrooms.
It was all about psychedelic mushrooms
that they would do it,
hide these mushrooms from the Romans,
and they would hide like what does the
magic and with the mushrooms can do and
the way they hid it from him,
Mrs.
Stories.
And they didn't even write it down for
like a thousand years.
They just told each other as a story for
a thousand years,
so it just became all fucked up and so
he breaks down like ancient words.
Keith,
he broke down the word Christ.
He brought it back to an ancient
Sumerian word that means a mushroom
covered in God's semen.
Nice.
Because they,
when they thought it was raining,
I was coming on the earth.
That's why things would come up out of
the earth,
like come wasn't bad debt.
So like when God would reign and he was
coming on the earth,
these mushrooms would just appear
because they didn't have microscopes,
they didn't know what a fucking lie a
spore is.
They couldn't see microscopic things,
so they didn't see any seed or anything.
And also these big mushrooms appeared
like the next day they grow quick and
they start eating them and they tripped
their fucking balls.
They don't want anybody else to know
about this.
So they tried to hide the information.
They were told either a high keeping it
from their enemies.
Wow.
Isn't that nuts?
God Zurich it off.
Isn't that.
That's how they used to look at him or
did he pull out some guidance
somehow?
You've got to figure out,
Daddy,
you got to
so good to have a baby right now.
Think about how good it feels to have a
baby right now.
It's an amazing,
incredible feelings,
but most babies now,
they live.
They live to be grownups,
ups to be adults.
They don't have to worry about them
getting eaten by lions.
You don't have to worry about plague,
but the people that live back then had
the same love for the kids as we do now,
but they couldn't help it,
so there were people were dying left and
right,
but there's nothing you can do to stop
it.
That must have been nuts,
man.
That must've been fucking horrifying.
Having kids just got well,
must be why they had all these rituals.
It was fertility.
Rituals are so important.
They wanted to have as many kids as
possible.
Roman times,
50 percent perhaps the people that have
the damn before,
what?
Adulthood that's can get it.
Only half of them make it turned out
that the condition he imagined what it
was or something like that.
That was on discovery.
So I don't know.
The history channel.
Don't quote me on that.
Like oh no,
that makes sense.
I don't remember that.
Even if it wasn't 50 percent,
it had to be a high number.
I mean they just didn't have someone
check that mortality rate and Roman
times.
I think it's 50 percent could be wrong.
Dude,
I've had two major surgeries.
Both my knees reconstructed,
both acs and one more minor surgery.
My meniscus surgery on my hand,
but if I lived,
you know,
thousand years ago,
I'd be fucked,
man.
That'd be fucked.
You wouldn't be doing Jujitsu?
No.
That wouldn't have happened to run into
him.
Plan to work it.
You learned have been a softball
champions.
Softball.
I smashed my biggest.
There's guys out there.
They're fucking champions in softball.
Like they're the fucking Mark Mcguire.
A softball.
There's guys out there.
We'll do this.
That create those.
Who is the Hicks and Gracie to find that
out.
It's been great.
So softball that.
How accurate can you be when you whip
that fucking thing around?
It looks dope.
That's nuts.
Then checks because it all.
I don't think I've ever seen the chicks
throw that hard regular.
Have you ever seen a chick throw it was
clearly the right way to do it?
Yeah.
Why did they throw into narrative that's
like,
no,
it's like it's like breaking the balls
and pool.
You know how you try to break the balls
really hard.
She wants like a little person.
They have like a loose wrist and just
smash is like a timing to it where
they're just knowing exactly how to put
their weight into it and just not like.
It's weird,
like Jujitsu should straighten things
when it comes to techniques and it's
like the more you do techniques,
the more those techniques just becoming
grain,
the way your body moves.
Your body just gets really good at the
movement so you can teach your body
move,
which is like a j.
shows control and credible founder Dan
Henderson is a monster.
He took.
First of all,
I'm just impressed.
Fuck these first round.
The first round he got face planted.
He got bold,
lasted like Henderson on the button.
Oh,
I do.
I erased it.
I arranged it.
Henderson hit him on the bus.
You have erased it.
You get it online.
We can get it online.
Most will watch captured.
Henderson faceplant face plants a field,
so blindly die for it.
He got cracked and Dan Henderson hits
him again for hard upper cut to an end.
It goes down again.
He got fucked up and that first one
chance.
But Danny came on strong in the second
round and the tennis shoes started fade
a little bit and jake shields started
taking them down,
fucking controlling them.
And they were saying that,
uh,
that Henderson has been having problems
with his back.
So you know,
he looked kind of stiff.
That could have been what's going on.
It could have been why couldn't,
couldn't stuff that take job,
but pants,
shields a good total control mountain.
I'm just a mountain of over and over
again.
And Henderson could not shake him,
couldn't finish them,
and never went for one arm bar.
But that's it.
Sports is 100 point.
Oh my goodness.
I have A.
Yeah.
This is ridiculous.
We're not supposed to do I for 20.
It's time to order pizza.
No,
wait,
can we just tv know it just takes.
They don't give a shit.
They do though.
Is people listening to this on itunes to
at this point in time that already like,
are we allowed to go?
I bet no one says no one.
It's like,
yeah dude,
they're all looking at.
Go for it.
Please.
Fuck.
I need to get more pizza.
Pizza,
everyone.
How come you haven't gotten an operation
that your eyeballs fixed?
Fuck you guys.
Fuck you.
Happy three 87.
Hey,
how come you haven't got your eyeballs?
Scared of that now and I'm not scared at
all.
I just haven't done it.
Would you want to do with about you?
Contrast is just so easy.
Like I don't even know that I never even
got caught.
Sometimes they might contacts in three
or four days and shit I don't think
you're supposed to,
but they don't.
You want to get them fixed.
Have the context.
Tells me that I'm making up little
things in your I now you can see better
how it is.
That means seeing is so fucking
important and you can fix it with a
little piece of plastic.
How did they figure that shit?
I didn't figure out contact.
Someone figured that out.
Jensen and to the counselor.
I want to say a documentary to think
about what all the shit that people can
do right now.
It's getting so crazy.
What the fuck is going to be the next
big thing because no one saw the
internet coming,
you know?
No one ever thought it was going to
affect people the way it's affecting the
human race right now because if they
did,
they would've never let it get out.
No,
no,
no.
Corporations would have ever wanted the
internet.
It's too tricky.
It was too hard to control.
It's too.
What?
What the fuck is gonna be?
The next thing is this isn't going to be
the last day of the grantor.
That's it.
Going to be like Hologram laptops where
you're just going to need like maybe a
little little block and then it just
blows up or something.
It's going to be New Orleans just
happened.
I think it's going to be neural implants
or the other idea that I had was not a
normal implant,
but that they figured out the frequency
of your brain.
Like what if they beat your brain
towards like a wifi signal,
but what if your brain,
like obviously you know,
input comes into your brain in the form
of hearing things and seeing things and
these electrical impulses or wherever
the hell sight and sound is created and
how you represent that stuff in your
head that's like,
those are like signals that are coming
in from,
from Your Eyes,
from your ordinance.
What if there's a way to get that signal
out into the air.
So instead of having to be directly
input into your brain with,
you know,
with just a,
with site signals and with,
you know,
the,
the signals that your ears giving.
What if there's a way to tune into the
whole mind like a Wifi,
but some sort of neural implant or
something that activates a certain
portion of the brain and literally
allows your brain to tune in to everyone
else's brain.
Like we all like share a giant hard
drive,
like that totally seems possible.
It seems to me like they're just.
They just have to figure out how that
would work and what kind of a frequency
that would operate under,
but if they can,
they can introduce all sorts of things
in the people's brains.
This guy,
they did an operation on him and they
stimulated a part of his brain and he
started there were,
I forget what they were trying to do.
It was this was an accident,
but in stimulating part of his brain,
he started remembering shit from his
childhood,
like in graphic detail.
It was happening right there,
right in front of them.
Like they literally figured out how to
charge and jumpstart your memories.
You know,
I think I do shit like that,
but they can.
They can introduce thoughts to people's
minds.
They can read vision that can revision
now.
They can put little things on your head
and you look at something and a computer
will show an image of what you're
looking at.
That's incredible.
It's not good.
It's not good image.
They haven't figured it out good yet,
but if you read letters,
you can see the letter and a picture.
Kathy.
Not yet.
Not yet,
but it's close.
Well then there'll be able to figure out
like memories tariff.
Exactly.
Close to world.
If we've realized that,
you know,
memories are completely unpredictable.
That memories are,
they,
they're so easy to scramble.
You know,
when,
when you think about like how much of
human history was just written down and
spoken on memories,
memory,
arguing with somebody about something.
Something happened and they're like,
that's not what happened.
You know,
like,
you know what?
We're just remembering and I have no
idea if I'm the one that's wrong or they
are.
But it's like,
I'd like to say like,
no,
you're remembering it wrong,
but it's like,
why do I think I'm the one you gotta you
gotta be real careful
that I went back to my home where I grew
up in and I hadn't been there in like 10
years ago and I remembered everything
different.
Man,
I'll never forget that my house look
different.
The fucking street looked different.
I thought this.
I thought the staircase was on a
different side of the street,
like I had it all fucked up in my head.
That's where I went to the place that I
lived at when I was three and an
apartment.
Then my dad got.
My mom was exactly.
I was shocked with the numbers go.
Different places changed though,
you know,
knock down a building and changed it
around.
You don't know.
That building was exactly the same.
Like how old were you when you got three
year olds?
Maybe four images from three.
That's out of me.
But anyway,
the street look at the Safeway.
Safeway used to be there at this time.
You're remembering having,
remember remembering the memory about a
year ago,
and then you remember the year that you
remember your memory of the
have those individual members for ours.
We're thinking about one little thing
can throw you off and then it shifts
your idea of,
oh no,
that's not what happened and this
happened,
and then all of a sudden you see it
better,
but you were just committed to the way
you saw 10 seconds was the incorrect
way.
It's not fucking reliable enough.
That's what I was thinking.
What does what I was thinking before
about like people like the reason why
turtles,
turtles live to be 100 years and people
will live to be 100 is I don't think you
can keep our purpose going and keep us
living because the way society seems to
work best is if people don't live long
enough to figure out that it's all
bullshit,
you know?
Because if they do,
then chaos,
restructuring,
everything goes to a different way and
that's not the way that humans are going
right now and the way we're going.
It's like some sort of a global
domination thing,
some sort of a technological singularity
thing.
We're moving further and further and
further.
If we were able to step back and as a
culture get old enough to realize how
silly that all is and realized how much
better life would be if we all just
relaxed and shared resources and be nice
to each other and treat the world as if
it were friends and work this all out
together,
but nothing would ever get done.
Things get done because people are
competing when people competing,
people hate the other people.
They're competing against,
whether it's countries or companies or
political parties or anything,
so when,
when,
when that kind of shit happens,
that competition is why we made newer
and better things.
If there was no competition like that,
it wouldn't be the pressure to be the
best at everything.
If you didn't hate the other people,
there wouldn't be this pressure to
dominate them and crush them,
but can live in a world like the Amazon
Indians can the whole world.
Well,
there's some reason why those dudes are
still running around with fucking pieces
of animal flesh.
Covering Dick is don't know if it's
wrong.
I mean,
that's right.
Maybe it is.
It's certainly an alternative,
but I think.
I think we have to look at human nature
as being natural and I think that if we
look at everything else being natural,
we look at the way you behave and the
way you know a monkey's behave.
We look at their simple lives as being
natural.
While we look at the course of humanity
is being natural,
we're.
We're pretending that it's something
that we all consciously control,
but if we do,
why is it so fucked up?
Still?
Why is there's so much political
corruption when we know there's so much
political corruption,
why are we still going to war?
What we know?
We know that wars are ridiculous and
that their only ways for profit.
Why do you keep continuing along the
same lines?
Even though rationally we must know a
certain point in time,
this is an insane way to live.
Well,
maybe it's because that's just the way
people live.
I believe we're moving towards with
that,
that this behavior pushes us toward
something.
It pushes us towards creation of
something global practice.
Something,
some,
some end of wrong little worlds
thinking,
you know,
it's all about us,
but meanwhile,
you know,
whatever's going on,
you're just like an end.
You're just producing an editor.
Zinc that's needs to collectively do
something world or something.
But we got our labs and it goes to what
would our was Ari was saying about the
parent's side,
like think about that.
Think about the animal that this
parasite,
the parasite lives and has no fucking
idea.
You know,
they have no idea where to distance at
all.
That has no idea that cat has no idea
what it is.
I mean,
the whole thing is bananas.
It's finance.
It's all interconnected.
Yeah.
Is it as possible?
So make those crazy cat ladies too.
Is it a few people aren't immune to the
fucking Paris.
I don't know why there is a certain cap
parasite that is infected.
A tremendous amount of the female
population in Brazil and a bunch of a
bunch of other countries.
And this is um,
a,
uh,
actual parasite that makes women more
docile.
Hmm.
Probably the same thing.
It was a no fear.
I have to look that up because I
remember that.
It,
it,
it does sound like that shit.
I know why women in Brazil.
I have to find this.
I have to Google this right now.
This,
this is too,
too strange.
I have to find this out because I can't
remember what it was when I read it.
Parasite in Brazil.
Cats,
women.
I got to find this fucking article,
mood altering cat parasites make women
friendly and manage the jerks.
Dude,
that's Brazil jerks.
I mean,
think about how many,
uh,
how many,
really friendly girls come from Brazil.
And how many super aggressive dudes.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
If you look up what Google would,
I looked up,
um,
you,
uh,
you come up with a quite a few articles
about it.
It's a parasite that causes rats to
sacrifice himself to cats.
May also change human behavior,
making women more outgoing and warm
hearted and men more jealous and
suspicious.
The toxo plasma protest is a shed,
a shed and cat feces which are then
eaten by rats,
infected rasp become fearless and the
presence of cats,
which makes them easier to catch,
which in turn spreads the disease to new
cats.
Holy Shit.
It makes women nicer and it makes them
Douche bags.
That's hilarious.
Nature is totally rooting against us.
Finding new ways to keep a fucked up.
How crazy is that,
man?
How crazy is that?
Because men who are more douchey are
more likely to fuck a bunch of different
women and and impregnate them like fuck
they're friends women and you know,
you know what I'm saying?
Like the more Douchey guy guidance,
the more he's got to do like creepy
shit.
Go get laid.
So the more likely that's gonna make
like excellence.
Some babies all over the place,
it's going to keep spreading the eye.
Maybe a nature likes Douche bags.
Well it's like it goes back to what I
said,
it's like,
it's almost like you don't really
achieve unless there's competition and
competition doesn't really mean anything
unless it's competition.
Like,
like primal,
you know,
a man who hate to you hate him and he
hates you and it really forces you to
work hard.
You know?
That's why companies fucking hate each
other.
Companies that compete against each
other or rarely friendly,
they fucking hate each other.
Maybe they're supposed to.
Maybe that's the most efficient way to
get things done.
You have to light a fire under someone's
ass in order to get the most
productivity out of them.
Hey equals productivity.
It's like your life would certainly be
better off if you didn't have that,
that,
you know,
that aspect too,
but you wouldn't be a successful aspect
to you though.
So,
uh,
so it's like a fucked up shit like war,
you know,
that's how it's supposed to happen.
That's a,
that's a terrible conclusion to terrible
conclusion.
But it might be that everything we do is
the way we're supposed to do it.
They have a jealous for war.
It's not,
I want to do it,
but someone's gonna do it,
you know,
it's just the way they've been doing
business forever.
It's going to take way too long for that
to settle down all these people that
promise that they're not going to have
war anymore.
But I've looked at Obama,
he promised that he was going to stop
all this.
Who's going to pull people out and just
more in the never George Bush playing
golf,
you know,
Obama's or play more golf.
And George Bush has,
I think it's the first term,
first year he played 33 times.
I said,
George,
I think a lot of flack for 20th times.
Obama's a very smart guy,
very good speaker.
That's really all I all I have to say.
Other than that,
I'm not
seeing anything different.
She stopped doing the things he said he
would do.
You know,
I don't know about the stimulus package.
I don't know what's going really happen
with that or whether that's because
that's too fucking complicated and no
one bothered.
Nah,
fuck it.
Well,
maybe documentary.
My problem.
My problem with all this stuff is where,
where do I put my attention?
How much time do I have in a day?
What do I want to think about?
Do I want to concentrate on?
Oh,
how are they fucking us?
Oh wait,
where's this more?
It was more corruption.
Come in.
What is this?
Do I really want to focus on that?
Focus on the fucking November ballot.
They legalized pot completely.
That would be insane.
Is that valid ren?
Eddie and myself are medical patients.
We are a California.
Yeah,
we're all sick.
I,
uh,
I've gotten injured up two surgeries.
It's all real and it's a nice calming
agent for you,
like during the day.
It's a perspective of answer,
right?
I just do it for the insomnia.
I say I don't smoke pot all the time.
I just smoked before.
I have sex before I do comedy.
Before.
Why comedy for Jujitsu before I know I'm
going to eat something delicious.
So it's not all the time.
It's just before cool shit to make it.
I almost feel like that whenever I'm
like,
Oh,
let me make this better and then I'll
get the burrito the first time that he
got up to me.
Hi can we went and got an ice cream
Sundae?
Uh,
so went on stage that night.
And you were talking about how great
that ice cream Sundae wise was the
greatest thing ever.
You've wrote material about how good it
tastes so good.
Right in,
right away.
The material made more sense.
Like I could write material right there.
By the first time I got home,
by the way,
the iron sheik smoke weed only during
his big fights before all hulk Hogan
fights.
That's so crazy.
That's.
He said he likes it.
He likes smoking weed after he trains at
after he wrestles,
unless it's a big macs and bob back when
all the whole Hogan.
He was always high during.
He knows a lot about what he knows his
shit.
He knows a lot of other shit too.
But the sheet is upon it.
And I got,
I got a fucking 45 minutes worth of
interview with them.
I might start posting these.
Right.
You weren't there when I tell the story
and I said I,
I walked in towards the end of it,
uh,
my buddy Danny calls me up and goes,
dude,
I'm gonna fucking meet Ian Cheek right
now.
How the fuck did that happen?
Because he's in town for like the calm,
calm or what a comic,
whatever,
like a comic book convention.
He goes and I twittered as manager and I
asked his manager that he could have,
if I gave them 200 bucks if we could do
the answering machine.
You wanted to make one,
like the one joe he has for me.
He loves it.
You want to have a to do his.
So the manager,
you know,
they need money,
the magicals come on down or you know,
we're at this hotel and I go,
oh shit,
he goes,
you want to roll?
I go fuck out.
So he jumped in,
went to the hotel,
but there were waiting outside and like
Danny was fuck,
it looks like they're in a big hurry
because he was texting him,
hurry up or you guys that we got to go
to the airport,
this clock,
I want you to give them 200 bucks to sit
and rap with them.
We get a lot of shit,
you know,
so um,
so fuck it,
whatever.
So let's do it really quick.
So he pulls into this hotel.
I don't like rude.
He's like,
oh,
we gotta go to the airport and just make
this quick.
It's like this quick like,
Oh man,
okay.
Whatever it is,
unless you want to take her to the
airport,
we're driving to the airport.
And you were like,
yeah,
yeah.
That way we get them for fucking 40
minutes man.
So he got the car video do,
we had this fun little restaurant.
Usually it's like 45 minutes of six.
Just take the whole 45 minutes.
Let's put online in one chunk.
Yeah,
definitely a documentary.
There's certain pieces that need to be
to make them funnier because we.
We didn't rely on it because he gets
paid.
He's like a like a super villain,
almost 70 and you just say,
okay.
Say and his managers,
his nephew,
let's say he barely speaks English,
is English in 10th grade and was in like
a gang.
He knows all these west West westworld
and fuck him.
And then his manager goes,
yeah,
a Britain down,
set them up and then take them home and
it's like these code words.
It's on the or the video,
I forget what it is,
slam and take them home and then glaze
them at the end or some weird lingo.
So then he goes,
oh hey,
don't really fucked up.
Fucked up out of some big moves.
Fuck,
I love this shit called capital club.
So he was made.
He was just say all these names.
They want to cut them off and like send
these guys the messages like,
Hey,
here's what I heard.
Talking mad shit.
It's always fuck you in the ass.
He just,
it's like he's got his,
his light.
I give me some money.
I'll say,
who do you want me to say?
It's like,
what is this personality like outside of
that?
I'm like a nice guy,
but he's not so he's not like that,
man.
You gotta see you gotTa.
See the clip?
I will put it online.
That's hilarious man.
That's one of those dudes that I would
love to meet and I was like,
Holy Shit,
I'm here talking to Hulk Hogan.
When I had to do an interview with him
and his brother,
you don't get fired up.
And I'm like,
fuck it dude.
She was probably all time number one
villain ever bigger than I.
She,
she wasn't really a villain.
Villain has sometimes she was fucking
evil.
He was Iranian nuclear war tax shit.
That was deep.
That was another bit crazier.
Bill and anytime I can barely walk
neglectable it got really badly hurt
from wrestling.
Fucked chester.
They take the snake Roberts,
he said,
I want to get dirt talking about whole
Hogan.
He's,
Oh man,
he's up.
He's a man.
Those kinds of to get operated on,
so such a tough life to do that.
Every night what they're doing is nutty
shit,
man.
Flying out of turn,
but he shot and he talks about.
He just does.
What is it?
He knows this guy who said things that
weren't very nice,
but anyhow.
What is it in her purse or teeth in the
morning?
No,
like his.
He started to interview like they asked
him,
some guys interviewing him and then he's
says Jujitsu legend and some guy's
interviewing them and says the video
starts on Eddie Bravo section and draco
Leno on the Geek on world champions
wheat on training and then they got the
Eddie Robinson champion.
Jeff.
I guess that's what I always heard about
him.
I always knew about him.
I never knew what he looked like until I
saw the video.
I never,
I would've never,
but especially one of the very highly
regarded one of the best guys.
That Baja racing,
older guy now products.
That would be something,
and the video starts off by who knows,
what about,
what do you think of Eddie Bravo and
then it was dr you're talking about
Eddie Bravo,
Johnny glow,
like he's just like,
oh yeah,
you really thought he said Johnny Bravo.
Like,
like that's even funny,
you know?
And then immediately it starts off with
just a bunch of backhanded compliments.
Like,
like,
uh,
oh yeah,
he's got some good positions,
but you know,
me and already had a high guard.
Like he was like basically saying that
Nino had my style of guard first when me
and Nina filed.
Guards are totally different.
They're nothing there.
Nothing there.
You're very difficult to often.
I mean we both play,
you know,
we do own a blocks and stuff and I got
the job a blocker for him,
but the actual style of our guards are
very different.
And uh,
obviously he doesn't know that,
you know,
he doesn't,
he hasn't really paid attention but
enough to know the difference.
Big fucking difference.
Um,
and then it says other stuff like,
uh,
it's just a bunch of backhanded
compliments.
It wasn't very,
but I thought it was hilarious.
And so,
uh,
so she knew about that.
Huh?
So the sheep knew about that?
Oh,
I don't know.
He said a lot of good things about me.
Thanks man.
Shit about me.
Yeah,
he likes me.
I really can't say anything bad about
the recording.
I mean,
I don't even fucking know.
Well,
you know what,
man,
I think,
uh,
there's a lot of people that don't know
you and you have a polarizing effect
because you're so controversial because,
uh,
just the way you look,
the way you act,
you know,
your behavior is very controversial.
You know,
what you think about,
like most Jujitsu people,
Jujitsu instructors,
they're not like wild musician
motherfuckers,
you know that or come up with Jujitsu
moves because they're high on weed like
that.
That fucks up with their whole dynamic.
Their whole view of what you know Jitsu
is.
And so if they,
because a lot of dudes don't know you,
I think that's where the controversy
comes in,
but they got to know.
You then realize that you're just sort
of completely openminded dude who's
willing to accept techniques from
anywhere and gives people credit all the
time and you invent moves or you teach
moves based on people's names,
you know,
like the doodle or did you know
different types of needs that you've got
the Jacques sweep that you got from each
individual.
You give them all credit.
They just don't.
They don't know.
They,
they see you getting all this credit for
this revolution,
revolutionary type of guard and so they
just assumed that it's all bullshit.
It's all over hyped,
but really it's not.
It's not on time.
Do you got some weird wild shit.
You put it together in like a real
system,
you know,
and it's.
And it's very legit and it's very
unusual and you're willing to talk to
anybody and have them fuck with it and
come up with their own stuff.
When you look at all the different
things that you've added from your
students,
look at all the moves for Edwin stuff.
You know all,
you know how you started incorporating
that in a class.
You know,
all sorts of different shifts.
The Japanese in that time,
so you're always,
you know,
adding whenever there's a new thing,
you're always adding it and always
giving the person credit created who
created.
That's one thing.
That's probably the one thing that,
that uh,
the biggest misconception is that you
take credit for things.
Yeah.
Is it?
I take moves and I changed the names and
then I pretend like I made them up and I
put a whole new name.
Like there's a lot of people out there
that think back and that's kind of true
or not really sort of 50.
It's totally the opposite.
It's the opposite.
I everybody fucking up.
Well,
like the twister,
you know,
when you first started doing the twister
and inside wrestling with.
Yeah,
that's a big.
That was the big thing because I never
called it the twister I got.
It was the of is guilty to me,
but the guillotines and John Job,
it was,
the good team was already taken and
Jujitsu and submission,
grappling,
all that shit.
So when I would call the good see now in
Brazil and just called it the twister
and stuck after a.
So a lot of people
think like,
Russell's Goldman did that in high
school,
man.
I'm like,
yeah,
you got to know the story.
So real quick,
it's easy to convince those guys if they
ask about me like,
what's up with this twitter thing?
Uh,
you know,
that's a guillotine.
And wrestling they go,
yeah,
he's got a bunch of groups like that
dude.
He just changes names and then real
quick now I got to dig myself out of a
deep hole with a lot of people like
that.
That's like a total opposite
misconception that I like take moons and
steal them.
And,
and that's,
I like,
I did it for awhile and then I had to
stop and slow down and change my ways.
And from day one,
my first book I give everyone credit my
Silverado do all that shit.
I've,
I get pissed off when people learn
techniques from someone else and I know
them personally.
I know where they got the move from and
then they start showing it to someone
and that'll bring up the person that
taught them.
That offends me.
I don't always remember to bring up
names,
but I tried to as much as I can.
Jujitsu moves as like a creative thing
that you're adding to like one big
gigantic piece of artwork,
like the martial art itself,
like when you,
when you invented a new technique,
like you invent some new sweep or some
new way to set up a Google plateau and
then you add it to the Jujitsu language.
Do you feel like that's what it is?
It's almost like you feel like it's like
a piece of art,
so it was something that you create and
people don't give you credit for
creating that and then people were out
there doing it.
It's like they're stealing your art
almost because they're going to do it
regardless what they want.
So that's the thing.
Anybody who was doing his shit,
he supports and he even had a cop,
you know,
like you,
you'd love that guy out there doing your
shit.
Yeah,
totally.
I mean I'm human.
I want,
you know,
if someone learns some ship directly
from me or my books or anything,
you know,
the right thing to do is get credit,
that's the right thing to do and not
giving credit is you did it,
you know,
whoever you learn a technique from the
crowd,
you've got to,
if you don't go into a strap on,
it doesn't take away from what you did
at all.
You know,
people think that somehow or another you
teach them a guy,
you know,
a certain way to set up a rear naked and
then he does it and then you give them
credit.
It takes away from him.
No,
it doesn't take away from that at all.
Not at all.
It's just the friendly thing to do.
And he sounded like daytime,
like I pull off a submission,
a that someone else in class showed me.
I'll always go from go it,
got it twice a day,
you know what I mean?
Do the same thing or the same thing.
Yeah,
that's important man.
It's,
it's important and it's,
it,
uh,
fosters that friendly attitude to come
out.
All I'm trying to do,
I mean I guess it feels good.
It's like a piece of art and something.
I always feel good when a new transition
comes up out of nowhere or someone else
and one of my students to me or we see
it on the Internet.
I get excited.
It's cool.
It's like another.
Those beans I'll do
it.
Have no idea how complex it is.
They really have no idea how many levels
and layers there say like I was talking
to Nathan,
we were talking about,
hey,
he trained with Marcello and I went down
to New York of training them a couple of
times and it was just talking about how
good marcella moves and how it's really
amazing to see someone operate on that
level and we just started thinking about
it,
like how humbling that is.
Like when you're around a guy like
Marcello or operator or something like
that.
Video.
Wait Online,
rolling through.
People just rolling through one after
another.
Just submitting a left,
right,
left,
right.
When,
when you see someone who's at that high
level,
you know,
it's like,
it's so humbling because you realize how
many gundam layers there are to this.
It never ends.
It's a more complex and more,
you know,
the guy shoots a pet,
gets faster and they're diving on shit
with more precision and their technique
is more crisp and more sharp and more
options and
there's 12 different ways that I can
count and they're maybe more 12 to toys
to play off your back.
Then that's what I can count.
Well distinctly different styles.
Like there's a difference you can tell
to the train die.
So look at Tom.
He's playing deep path.
He's ex card,
he's playing a lockdown.
Hap,
he's playing 50 slash 50 guard.
He's planning a butterfly gardens and
Robert Gard,
there's 12 of them that I could count.
There might be more of a Deli,
Heba Guard,
spiral card,
all that shit.
There's so many.
It's so complex.
I mean,
I've been doing Jujitsu for 16 years.
I suck at most of those gardens.
Like I'm not that good at.
I might have been della Heba Guard
doesn't exist there,
so that's a whole different stock spiral
guard,
inverted guard.
I never do any of that stuff.
I never played 50 slash 50 guard.
I never did any of that shit.
I mean I have like four or five guards
and there's like 12.
There's a lot of them that I don't do.
There's so much like all these world
champions like Rafael Mendez and marina
and all these guys.
This is totally different than mine.
Totally.
Like if we've taught for our seminars
eats,
I mean two different worlds,
you know what I mean?
There's so much to learn which path
you're going to take.
You know what I mean?
I've been doing like again 16 years and
I'm still putting new weapons into the
game.
That's.
I make sure that there's always new
projects that are always,
always,
always got to be a new projects and
those projects could take one to three
years to get where you need them to be.
The Doris is still my project from like,
you know,
five years ago,
I'm not as good as the top guys with.
Does a pretty good and I'm not,
I'm not as good as,
I still got some more levels to pop
through,
but you know the over the last year,
year and a half via teens and north
south suck with those,
but they've been on my project.
That's when I go against the scrubs.
When I go against the white belts and
new guys,
you know,
I'm not going to do anything that I'm
good.
I'm going to only get shit that I suck
at and try to train my body.
I would get into north south and I go,
this feels awkward.
I don't know how Danny does it,
you know,
and,
but I would get in there and try to get
as far as I can and I'd lose it.
I'd go do something else.
That's cool.
I'll come back to it and try it again.
We're not stopping.
I'm not really pleasing.
Right.
Trying to move my lucky focus on it and
after awhile then you get into like,
oh,
okay,
this is feeling good.
I think,
you know,
eventually it'll come and you have to
remember that people forget that because
a lot of people when they try something
new they go,
well,
it feels kind of awkward.
Fuck that.
I'm gonna.
Go back to my shit.
I don't know.
He's weird.
He's got some strange too big.
You got to remember that all moves.
Feel awkward in the beginning and if you
want this movement,
doesn't matter.
You can master listening if you want it,
you can be a carrier with this.
It's up to you how many reps who are
willing to put in,
you know,
and in Jujitsu,
the only sport where you can spar 100
percent every day.
Everyone just sparse there.
Like maybe they'd put in as few reps as
possible.
Most people have that mentality back
unless you force them.
And that's what I do.
I force my guys because I know they're
going to get lazy and a guy said,
okay,
everyone do 15 those,
20 of that and make sure to do that.
And like I write it on a board and I
just kicked back and you know,
chill.
They're not going to do it.
You gotta have people need people.
That's why they hire trainers.
They can do everything.
They know all the exercises.
They know they can be.
They just need some of the foursome and
got someone to force you and you're
paying them.
Then it's easier to go to that shit.
Never do to actually get to try it.
For me,
I just look at everything.
Most things because like longterm
projects,
like what?
How many cycles have you gone through
with this technique and eventually by
third or fourth cycle,
once you hit it bad left,
now he's doing really well and look at
them.
Yeah.
It's hard to motivate yourself to push
yourself.
It is definitely important.
And pushing.
Rolling.
Uh,
so much more fun.
Drills.
Yeah.
Actually.
Can you imagine getting on a video game
and do you ever get on the practice?
Just practice the little movements over
and over,
like 50 times.
Like,
okay this.
Do people do that?
Like a room where they can just practice
movements and now they're getting really
good with all the moves and they do all
the techniques
that it's like a workout they do.
Wake up is based on map.
It's based on map systems.
So there's a bunch of different maps to
play on.
But one of the most important things
about playing quick when you're in a one
on one tool is to understand the map.
You're got to know where the guns are
out there hitting.
You got to know where you're going to
control the map.
So what you've gotta do is you've gotta
make sure you're not every fucking,
every minute area and you can move
around.
So they practice their practice like
special jumps and rocket jobs.
Practice jumping into certain areas and
so they don't get to have a really far
and then crumble.
So they'll practice that shape their
practices so they have complete command
of the map so they can move around the
map anywhere they want.
And then they practice timing.
When the,
uh,
the new version,
because you were playing the best person
though is quite free to me.
Quite force,
pretty bad ass.
That's the latest I think,
quick for us to last because it takes
years to make,
you know,
everyone they didn't know.
They came up with a new tool every year
when they get better and better.
I know.
Anything about video games
does this,
like the graphics and the amount of area
you can travel to always bigger getting
bigger and bigger.
Massive with orange juice or something
like that.
Role player games,
massive world.
It's like an artificial world again
where you can just travel for miles and
meet new people and show people,
live their whole lives inside those
things
and they're actually real people and
they're the real people.
Real people playing.
The people have lost their mind when it
comes to these things.
I never even heard of that.
People Starve people.
There's two people in Korea but their
baby starve
while they are nourishing their online.
Maybe they have fake baby online and
they were taking care of that baby while
they're real baby starve to death.
And Dean Boston marbles.
That's crazy.
People are living in artificial worlds
eight,
10 hours a day and addicted to it.
What's it called?
There's a bunch of world of warcraft.
There's a,
there's a everquest.
There's a.
what's the other one?
The sims.
There's um,
uh,
there's another one.
Something line.
There's no,
no,
no.
That's the,
that's the cool with the advantage.
So efficient one.
How many people on second life maybe was
called second life for a second.
Do there's 13,000.
Two hundred and 10 people.
No,
no,
no.
Look above.
People are dropping off.
They're like,
what the fuck am I watching?
Watching three retards stoned out of
their minds.
And I've talk to a camera.
Thirty thousand,
200,
10.
All this shit isn't boring.
It's the 4:20
episode.
If they're all with us or with us.
I passed out on park today.
Well,
I've been close like two or three times
a month or two in a real life is like,
oh my God.
And then I imagine that jumps in the
bed.
I think on the floor.
The top of my head.
How much weed?
Not that much,
dude.
Not that much and it happened to his
girlfriend I had once and it was like
she had like one kid.
It wasn't anything major.
Just what I saw someone do that we gave
the.
That chick was working on fear factor
and that was one of the production
people.
We're all,
we're all in New York or outside of.
We all went out there filming there for
the weekend instead of Bar,
have a drink,
get as much smoke,
someone to never smoked to joining the
ship.
One big hips train wreck and her eyes
rolled back in her head and she was
dropped.
I thought she was faking,
pretending like I was part,
so I'm so I'm going to pass out.
I thought she,
she's being silly,
like we got to catch her up as she was
falling down to the ground.
The girlfriend was like that and I was
like,
what are you doing?
And I understand that she was going
down.
Did you catch him?
Nope.
Did you make
an effort,
an effort scheduled popcorn so that the
fucking check drop.
So you didn't have to drop your popcorn
and probably wasn't gonna be able to
catch her anyway.
What you need to get a chance.
I didn't understand what was really
happening,
but it happened to me yesterday.
How many,
how long have you been?
Data's checked a few months.
Oh,
attached were you to her.
Right.
So we bummed out when she bumped her
out,
she felt.
Yeah,
I didn't quite get it until she was
fully down and paint.
Because you feel about responsible.
Somebody else.
It gave us Wednesday.
Zombieland did you watch this season of
celebrity rehab?
I watched one episode that check from
one day at a time.
Mackenzie Phillips rooming with this
country x country center.
You as epileptic seizures and she would
always like in the middle of this
conversation she was just telling
Mckenzie
she's breaking breezy.
It's not required that mother Charles
after the commercial.
Oh my God.
Have you guys seen shreds?
Shreds shreds is a thing you guys are
doing.
They're taking music videos and redoing
the music like I just saw from Germany.
They redo the music set as lipstick and
totally as perfect as possible.
But the worst voices,
everything's attitude and everything
inside the cabinet.
So you see this.
It's like the worst brought.
Yeah.
Jerry,
like they suck.
Let's watch it and we'll.
Anyway.
You want to journey.
It's funny.
They did one on Mac dance,
a dance at the center and he's friends
with this guy now and he said when he
showed it to him too,
he got really offended at the journeys
and journeys.
I,
you know,
they're like amazing musicians and
singers.
Okay.
I looked up shreds.
Journey treads,
wet shreds.
Journey.
That's it.
Any way you want to eat or ed.
I think if we're going to be within the
journey,
just a junky shreds.
That's it.
That's at the top.
And you make it to the audience.
Watch junkie shred.
You guys going to have to look up junkie
shreds
junkie.
Jerk knee.
Jerk jerk commercial journey.
Like journey.
Oh,
journey down.
I didn't get it either.
Sure.
It's genius.
That's very funny.
That's good.
Shit.
You guys to watch it.
I just sent it to a twitter already.
Can do that.
So easy.
It's so easy to do stuff like that.
Now to edit video and put it online,
like it'd be nice to be hard to actually
listen to the song on earphones record
here.
Right along with them as they're doing
it.
Yeah.
What'd you can do now?
A lot of people have already seen it.
Go look up van Halen
or,
um,
different.
Different.
That was some funny shit.
Yeah.
It was funny.
I try to read some of those.
We might be too high and we're doing
this.
Should,
should be illegal.
Ari,
that bladder?
No,
that was loud.
Yeah,
sorry.
Well that recovered it and they do that
the best way.
Kids threads.
I heard you were publishing it.
Scientific paper in neuroscience.
That's hilarious.
If that wasn't true,
I would be a Carlson.
Been seeing it.
Somebody wrote some shit in the Arabic.
Arabic does the cool.
Doesn't it look cool?
That shit looks Arabic.
Yeah.
That's probably the coolest second.
Writing on the plan.
Probably Cooler than Chinese or
Japanese.
It looks like something elegant to it,
you know,
it's like cool to see it on your wall.
You know,
it was like art.
So this chick wants to fuck you.
Do SLURP,
Bella?
She's back.
Oh Shit.
She says,
explain the name name's Bella.
Where'd you get that from?
Who gave it to you?
Did you doubt yourself?
People in here,
man.
There's no way are we gonna have to keep
an eye on it to catch her response.
Can I get Dave Chappelle on here
sometime?
I would love to hang out with Dave
Chappelle,
but I don't know him that well.
We did a show a couple of times and one
time it's just because I was walking on
the street and random and other times
the fear factor one,
the one we ran into was hilarious.
Remember that you would have been in New
York.
We're just walking on the street and I'm
like,
oh,
like dish called a mustache on things
like,
hey joe,
you want to be in my show?
Was like,
okay,
and was that a nowhere?
No,
it's Times Square.
Just walking down the street.
That was what a Dave Chappelle show,
you know,
like nobody had any idea it was even
coming out.
And then when it came out like right
away.
Well that was the best show ever.
But the first case,
I'm sure it was like,
no,
let's leave it.
That one knocked it out of the park.
That was the best shot with that.
The first sketch ever.
And so I don't know.
I know it's the first sketch on the top
25 because I think when he said it,
I think I remember it going like we lose
my friends said I shouldn't do this.
It almost seemed like he had introduced
to other scriptures already,
but just for the audience knows the
answer to this.
But that's a good question.
That seems like intelligence.
The audience here.
We could find out anything about that.
How about when we couldn't remember that
dude's name earlier?
Dennis hopper just knocked up.
Yeah.
That's incredible.
Yeah,
I mean there's,
there's a 1600,
66.
One,
six,
six.
We're evil.
We're officially
do got a lot of viewers.
Right.
And some other shiny happy Jihad.
Listen man,
don't be mixing my shit up with that
shit because I don't know what you're
saying about the chicken,
Nevada that got sent to life in prison
because she talked to 14 year old boy.
Just wanting to try to get them to have
sex with her and she grabbed his hand
and put it on her tit and try to get an
a fucker.
Got Life in prison.
That is the mandatory sentence for that
life and business and management.
She's 14,
the kids 14 years old and she's like 34
some shit and she grabbed the kid's hand
and put it on her tick and she said she
was drunk and she doesn't remember any
of it and this bitch is going to.
Oh,
that's possible.
Don't remember who did it.
All she did was put it,
you know,
obviously the bitches crazy and she
needs to do like a,
a night in jail or maybe a week at the
most,
you know,
like what would it be like to spend one
month in prison that will fucking
destroy a lot of your life.
Yeah.
And people are like,
oh.
And he's got at least 10 years.
Thinking about what a month,
year in prison would be horrifying.
Terrible,
terrible.
And for just getting a boy to touch at
10,
I mean,
yeah you should have done it,
but come on,
you're supposed to like slap on the
wrist.
Tony Kanal there so that.
So she's not even eligible for parole
for 10 years.
She has to go 10 years before she was
even eligible.
I'd like to know the details of that
shit not been done.
You guys just fucking support held area
and I'm going to send an unbelievable.
It's hard to believe that people are
that stupid.
I would give someone like her that.
I mean that's why it's an interesting
story.
So when you're in class got thrown out
and you do like nothing or school but
share and it's like,
no you didn't,
you were moving over and told you to
stop.
That's all well and good.
But that was the charges with the
charges were,
is um,
lewdness minor or some shit like that.
She's machines for awhile.
Probably wasn't the first time raising
feed stocks deck on the little kids.
Doesn't stop.
Well,
if she did it to this kitchen,
probably done the other one.
It's not like she's been fucking grown
men,
it's just that they're just take time.
It's not like,
you know,
like all of a sudden out of nowhere she
says,
let me just dive in this 14 year old
thing.
She's done it before,
so it's just not particular about who
she blows,
you know,
that's all that is.
She's just a crazy bitch,
but she didn't have to go to jail for
the rest of her fucking life.
That's not know.
They're trying to put kids in Jennifer's
sexting and trying to make it illegal
for girls to share their same child
pornographer not notes of course.
Right.
Do what are they doing it to each other
and childhood setting through their
boyfriends.
One of your questions store a bunch of
spend it.
I think it was like nine girls got
suspended from school because they had a
bunch of pictures that they took and put
on their myspace page in between school
when they're not at school,
like during the summer break.
So when it came back to school,
there was suspended because of sexy
pictures of them.
I suppose they're like sucking fingers
sticking out and underwear and stuff and
there were like 14.
They're just doing a normal horse shit
and they got suspended.
So the girls are suing the school.
They're going to win.
I mean if it can go on my space,
you can't tell someone they can't do
something during their off time because
you're not like it,
but you're just because you're teaching
them,
you know,
when did the these fucking retards,
whatsapp people access and go to school.
What you could access.
That's cool.
If you had access to my space at school,
I don't know what kind of Internet
access to have at school.
Yeah,
but either way the kids should be able
to put.
Everyone wants to be a war so it'd be a
more.
You can't legislate against that and you
certainly can't punish them for shit to
do.
You're acting like you're in fucking
mom.
Like you're.
You're saying you don't want them in
school because of what they're going to.
It's going to give other people a bad
impression of your school.
Is that what it is?
Because she's in her underwear online.
Like shut the fuck up.
So this is one of these dummies because
that are,
that are teaching our kids today and
that's the problem.
There's a bunch of.
Were fucking audience,
you know.
When did they become the parents?
When did they become the,
you know,
the moral arbitrators and what,
when did they become the people that
dictate now how people are supposed to
behave.
You know,
if you don't have a problem with your
kid sticking her ass up in the air and
space and you're the teacher,
you should be like,
whatever.
I'm going to teach you some science and
you get through life and enjoy yourself,
but with the teachers will step in and
say you shouldn't be in your underwear
when you're mad at school.
Like fuck you.
Who Do you just teach?
Just teach me.
You don't,
you don't get to fucking shut my life
down because you know you don't like me
in my underwear.
Seattle.
I said that.
I said in the first person I got was a
14 year old girl,
was a secret fantasy.
He didn't even notice that.
How did they?
14,
15 years old.
Do you can't stop checks from doing
worship?
They arrested a 15 year old girlfriend
child.
I'm free because she sent a dude a in
her class,
a picture of repurposing,
so they arrested her.
They eventually charged her with a use
of criminal tools in a criminal tool.
Was a cell phone,
wasn't charged the community.
Is that.
That's incredible.
That's a tiny little facts.
Izzy.
Yeah,
Brian's fucked.
I love you.
I'm also invited.
Oh,
that's so sweet for Brian Wilson here.
Have done.
Brian is Brian Bent into a school and he
was eating some yogurt and bit down
first of all,
signed.
And that's supposed to bite that God
damn hard on yogurt.
You Know How hungry is he?
Bit Down into his metal spoon.
Yeah.
What are you doing?
Biting it.
I don't need to go over all the plastics
bullets from now and for you.
So he bit down on us.
Go and focus to waste.
I am.
Scott said he's going to put them in a
triangle choke.
How dare you?
I don't like being caught trying.
That's uncomfortable.
Scared.
Scared that you're scared.
Now you really got me scared.
I'll just say he was stoned,
eating yogurt,
yogurt,
thinking about yummy ticks.
Just get outside of the clamp down.
I'm thankful.
We talked about all the things I wanted
to talk about.
I talked about the lady in Nevada.
We talked about strikeforce and they
have any other comments?
Eddie?
Mike Whitehead got busted for sexual
assaults.
That's not good for the movement.
My Damn,
that sucks.
I was he drunk too.
I hope it's all bullshit.
Jack Jack Hair Dye and you know,
he had a massive heart attack a year ago
and is based on.
So they just thought she was dead the
whole time.
I didn't know who was a person they
thought he was done.
There was a bunch of people sat like,
I think even doug sent out an RFP with a
lot of people were saying he was dead
and so there the rumor going around but
it wasn't.
He was dead,
but he was basically like barely.
It is basically the.
Wow.
I don't know the scientists of the
medical details,
but I know that he was in really,
really bad shape from the time of that
till till now.
So who was it,
sorry,
it wasn't that he was just really a
powerful marijuana activists that
started out his life as like this gold
water republican type guy who was like
really anti elite and then he'd gotten
divorced and smoking pot with this woman
that he had just met this new woman.
He took a chance and there's a single
guy and you know,
hanging out with some chicken and really
kind of was blown away by it and then
know,
fell in love with the effects of
marijuana and instead of looking into
the history and then he put up this
really fucking amazing book called the
emperor wears no clothes and it's all
about this marijuana already been
general.
Yeah,
putting him in jail.
The reason he went to jail because he,
before he wrote the book,
he was already at like a marijuana
activist for certain things.
There's so many ways you could fight for
marijuana,
but I forget exactly what he was
fighting for.
In the very beginning.
He was protesting in front of a federal
building.
Reagan showed up.
Reagan a total people that federal
building have handled.
You had the cops come and arrest
everybody.
All they had to do was pay like $20 a
ticket or something.
He refused the pad and he went to jail
for a year.
Yeah,
he went to jail.
That's where it was.
Good for him.
He,
that's where you had the time to write.
The emperor wears no clothes.
Jaylen.
That's amazing.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
It's a good book too.
It's really very detailed.
If you want to know anything about the
history of propaganda and the hemp being
made illegal,
everybody thinks that the reason why
marijuana is illegal because it's bad
for you.
I mean if you ask 100 people $75,
we got to tell you it's bad for you.
It's something that doesn't bring it
down,
which causes some problems,
but that's not why it's illegal.
It's illegal because when they figured
out a way to process him,
fibers more effectively.
That came up.
This thing called the decorticator.
There's a machine that grinds up to
happen and them with the fibers easier
to process.
William Randolph hearst owned the paper
companies and he also owned newspapers.
So these paper companies,
you know,
they make paper out of a fucking and
this tap won't paper was much better as
far superior and it was a competing
product so he wanted to make an illegal.
So when he decided to do was print
newspaper articles where they said that
blacks and Mexicans were raping white
women.
I knew it and the reason why they were,
they said the reason why they were
raping white women,
it's because they were smoking this new
drug called marijuana.
So when Congress made marijuana illegal,
they didn't even know they're making the
textile,
you know,
the,
the fabric,
you know,
all the things that hemp can make.
It didn't really even know they were
making that illegal to.
They have no idea.
It's really completely ridiculous.
The fact that it's stuck from the 19
thirties all the way to here,
2010,
even though we know it's ridiculous.
I mean you can go right now what on the
corner store and buy Jack Daniels and
trick ourselves to death easy.
We walked in with there right now,
we each bought a big ass bottle,
a gallon jug of Jack Daniels.
All three of us in life.
No one would bat an eye.
That's lethal doses we just bought
lethal dose is about,
and we can just come here and three of
us would drink those drip down Jack
tennis until her body literally shut the
fuck down.
That sounds cool.
How crazy is it that people don't even
bat an eye that marijuana should or
shouldn't be illegal?
It's,
of course it shouldn't be legal.
If you can go and buy Jack Daniels.
Ridiculous.
I'm fucking hungry.
You know what?
End this thing.
Good.
I think we've done enough.
I think we've already talked about.
So you know,
I think they're born enough.
Anderson Silva,
Sandy's going to take all the UFC belt.
You know what?
Maybe Anderson Silva's board at 185
pounds.
Maybe.
That's the reason why his last
performance wasn't up to par.
You know who the fuck knows man?
You don't know until you're inside that
dudes had no.
He's obviously brilliant.
You know,
and it's Friday and he's probably a very
complicated dude,
you know,
but I think I would like to see him
challenged that Shell fight is gonna be
very interesting.
Chael Simon's going to talk a lot of
shit and he's going to attack it and
yeah,
August I think it's going to be in Salt
Lake City.
Well,
she also has a real good rest fucking
well you should come in,
which was really impressive because you
should have time start to be like this
real powerful grappler.
Chilson just manhandled them,
grapple the shit out of him.
Daddy beat chess.
Then it'd be a landmark for now.
I'm just like,
oh,
that really opened a lot of people and
so now he gets his way.
He took on a really explosive with
double leg take downs and you don't see
that often.
You see that?
He does.
He's like GSP with wrestling.
She fought Demian Maia before that and
you've got triangled.
You got a got taken down as soon as you
hit him with like a lateral or some sort
of a thrill.
It's really impressive.
And Damien mounted them and then stopped
the triangle from the mountain and pulls
up on top of them and tapped into drag.
It's a really sweet is there too,
but you know,
the Damien minor thing,
you know,
if that guy catches,
catches you,
he's really good at that.
And she also has been caught in the
past.
That would be an interesting thing.
If Anderson could submit him off of his
back,
that would be fantastic.
Because you know,
Chael Sonnen at some point in time,
Anderson doesn't lock them out
immediately.
So someone's going to have Anderson not
as back,
you know,
invested catches them was coming in,
which is always possible.
But they understand
crawling,
feeling tight,
close.
There's going to take a submission to
friends in the guard and passing the
garden a little more serious.
I have a feeling.
Yeah,
I don't think he's gonna come out
because he gets caught off guard because
he likes the column in the garland pound
in the garden.
You can get caught,
you know,
look at that car and airbnb kind of
caught,
you know.
And he's awesome.
He's awesome at Jujitsu,
but it wants shale.
Finally realizes that it needs to get
really good at passing and mounting and
taken aback flock once he realizes that
he needs to adapt the GSP strategy.
Once he looks at GSP fights and says,
Holy Shit I should be doing with GSP is
doing.
Once he makes that decision will be
unstoppable.
Serious reason why he does great,
but then you know he loses,
he does great,
but he moves his because he is not
taking guard,
passing and being safe in the garden and
passing as the number one priority over
and power in that and the full guard.
The only should really pound in before
God to open shit out.
Like passing should be your number one
focus.
Look at GSP passing is this number one
That is the correct attitude.
That's important.
Strategy.
Jackson said about GSP.
Greg Jackson said the fact that he
didn't want to GSP to pass the
gardening.
We took it down.
He said,
just don't pass his garbage route.
He was.
He was being could it
saying you couldn't pass his guard,
that he wasn't passing it and he was
like,
I guess we thought he was wasting energy
just wanting to feed them up from inside
the guard.
You know that.
Then she goes towards good from the half
guard.
You didn't get it.
I don't agree with that strategy at all
ever.
I would never do that,
but I can understand it in a way where I
can see that the after GSP passes guard
and Martyrdom Dang hard.
It would give this back.
Then he would post up and then
eventually shake them off and they would
stand up again that every time.
So you've got.
Jackson was looking at it as like it'd
be past the guards amount.
The NIGGA that mentioned stand up as it
gets back up and it gets up.
So I think just do it.
Just like staying this guard.
He can't get up from there.
He can't get up from the guard,
he can't get up once it gets back,
you know.
So just standard gardens,
get the w don't take a fucking chance on
this guy.
That's like the
super conservative strategy,
which I understand,
but I think GSP was doing five and I
think you should always go for the
finish and always go for the past almost
twice.
He almost had,
so yeah,
you don't.
You don't want to.
You don't want your job,
and they were working on it afterwards.
They're working on tightening.
What he was doing wrong with setting up
is Kamora telling him to hit it at a
different angle.
I don't know.
I don't remember how he did it.
Did you have to leg over the face in San
Controller to the other leg over the
face?
I don't remember what side control,
but that gap.
The Camorra looks strong.
The arm bar looks strong for a couple
seconds,
man.
I'm bobby's been back way back for a
couple seconds to Dan Hardee just rented
it out.
We'll just face the mat.
Turned himself over and Dan only had two
scratches on his under his right eye and
he wasn't hurt as arms refine and some
may has amazing that he went five rounds
of GSP and he barely had a couple of
mics on it.
Go back and ask you this man.
No parties a tough dude.
He's such a smart guy too.
So good at shit.
Talking so good at those interviews that
I have.
You know,
it's like,
it's such a tricky thing because in one
way that's like Kinda like anti,
like with the martial arts is supposed
to stand for talking shit and you know
that when dudes do talk shit they make
it so much more interesting.
Yeah.
I think they talk shit back in ancient
times.
Like Samurais against we dudes and all
that.
I said I think they touched it.
Yeah.
It's a tactic.
It fucks with people's heads.
Jumped ship.
Terrible.
My Dick doesn't want to make you
something like that.
What is it is a tactic,
you know,
fucking dudes heads.
It is like a legitimate technique.
The problem is that everyone thinks
they're doing so well and I like rarely
actually feels people off their games.
That was witty issues sometimes to mix
it.
Douchey.
The two guys are just talking shit to
each other now sometimes you know,
you know,
but when guys are good at it,
but it wasn't like personal interview.
I'm going to be honest with you,
I got when I'm going to go out and give
it my all,
that's all I can do.
What else do you want me to do?
Here's the deal,
man.
I don't really have a lot of job
options.
I need some money,
you know,
and it's not a lot of money,
but fuck it.
I need to fight and you know,
seeing that it's going to be a sound on
tv a couple of times and I thought,
you know what?
I'm to make some cash with that.
My favorite was Anderson and one of the
times when they go back and forth,
it'll tell you what,
that guy said it.
You say something and it goes like
divorced guy.
I said,
well,
he's fucking drama school.
But.
So,
uh,
they said you don't understand.
Like I said,
he's going to get you down,
you know,
Algebra submission.
It was just like,
that's a great tactic.
You know what I'm saying?
That's the smart way,
smart way to tell her that Anderson is
pretty good when it comes to cit
talking,
how casual economy gets,
but apparently it gets very angry.
I mean,
when you saw that Chael Sonnen fight men
or the rather Damien Maia fight,
he gets real angry,
you know Damien Maia,
whatever the Fuck David am I said really
made him bananas and that second round,
I don't know what the fuck was said a
lot,
but have you ever seen him like that
before?
Ever?
Just screaming,
screaming shit,
talking like that never would have been.
What would happen again in mind when he
bought boots and an Anderson Silva's and
what a Danny Meyer started doing.
Some fucking windmill break would stop.
What if it just started to break?
That's crazy.
It's like right in the middle.
You just started break dancing.
You know that thing where it's like they
don't dress it.
They spend.
That would be awesome.
I could do that.
George St Pierre to break dance.
You remember?
He used to do that a little bit and
something's really,
really good when you attack someone like
that,
like he just fucking spun out a big
propeller energy.
People imagine that's a fucking break.
That would be bad ass,
man.
I bet the break dancers would start
making up like this and it was fucking
switched positions and they can break
down a break dance card to have capital
or a gun together with break dancing and
it created a new.
Marsha said,
let's spending like a tsunami of things.
Just dive in.
You're going to get fucking balls and go
right to the headspin when you spend on
your head and then slide your legs out.
Fucking.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it'd be great.
I think that's probably a good board yet
we're talking about.
Yeah.
Let's talk about that real quick while
you're here.
What did you think about Shinya Aoki?
Gilbert Melendez.
Very interesting fight.
You know,
Gilbert Melendez is awesome and the
guard and he did a great job at staying
away from any danger in it.
I think maybe once or twice Aoki at m
and ms dot controlling,
smashed against the cage.
That was a bad mother fucker know
Gilbert Times.
Awesome.
Timing is standing up,
was wicked.
He stayed on top of him.
You know what I mean?
The only way that strategy was going to
work for him,
you know,
state avoiding the gardens,
if he could beat him in standard
exchanges,
and it definitely did because he lived
in these theaters.
Deacon is asked,
you know,
that that really map the risks,
wants enforcement on.
That was good.
He got,
he got the arm trapped a couple times,
but typically just right the fuck out of
it.
And it was never in any danger at all.
So that was a big fight for him,
don't.
He's just not as good with the fucking
with regular shorts.
So it was Jay shows contract
demonstrated for us because it
supposedly.
Yeah.
Which is amazing,
but if they really let him fight without
a contract saying that if he wins that
he's still in contract.
I don't know how that stuff works.
I didn't know you could do that.
I guess you can if you're not willing to
sign a new contract against him.
So he felt like.
I think jake shields was upset because
he felt like they were not respected.
They didn't promote him enough day.
Mostly.
Most of the promotion that they had was
mentioning Dan Henderson and because he
was on his last fight to be a big deal,
I mean Dan's a legend from to time pride
champion in two different weight
classes.
So that was a big deal for them.
A big acquisition.
They thought he was going to be the big
star,
so they,
they were hoping that jake shields would
lose,
I guess,
given the right away the other guy off
this first fight,
the first fight in the organizations and
title fight,
you know,
on CBS and a crazy ass fucking fight to
whoever thought that jake shields bill
to take Dan Henderson down that many
times.
Just order pizza and watch it.
All right then.
That's it.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this was the first annual for 20
podcasts.
Uh,
I think we've got some good shit we
talked about in there.
I think we lost the train of
conversation too much potato chips
you're going to have,
considering the fact that we got
completely vaporized.
It was a really,
uh,
it was,
it was not bad.
Next week I should have couches in here
and it'll be all set up and then the
week after that it will be my twitter.
Yeah,
twitter is Eddie Bravo,
twitter APP.
Eddie Bravo.
Every bottle for Joe Rogan.net.
I'm trying to get Joe Rogan.
If you got Joe Rogan hollow out and they
go,
let me know.
I like to get that stuff.
Thanks guys.
Later.
You ever broke one of his bags?
Firefox is frozen again.
This is the second time that I've shut
this off and so everybody can still hear
me right now.
It won't let me log out.
Was it.